je dis ça va ça va ça va très très bien
c'est notre grand paris tonton d'écouter
le grand paris avant de commencer du
coup un donc eu très très chaud
ah bah je vous en cause dès que j'ai le
grand paris celle où le grand paris tout
tout et tu sens que tu es le grand paris
non quand tu les écoutes mais si t'es
pas à paris ouais moi je peux le grand
père lui même chanson non mais doni doni
on est le grand paris sans être parisien
fin des gages à huy dong est forcément
qu'il était le grand paris aussi face au
rejet du grand paris sans être parisien
il le dit dans la chanson
notre attention oui mais du coup enfin
où sont les limites de ce grand paris
quelque part ça s'arrête là où centre
ville de paris dont potes je sais pas je
sais pas du tout ça s'arrête il part en
fait cela fera sentir à cheval tête mène
des rappeurs américains il devrait
chanter ses chansons i'm the big
pariscope c'est chez moi
bic paris bb bon alors aujourd'hui j'ai
des petits sont des toits
malheureusement tu entendras pas avec le
stream dac
si je mets des trucs mais des petits les
petits machins comme peut-être vraiment
il y en a que 3 tu vois on est un peu on
est un peu juste mais un petit à petit
ça va arriver non à présent plus que le
stream dès qu'il est là je vais montrer
à l'écran tu vas pas le vendre plus que
t'as pas le partage des comptes en pls
me tremper j'ai compris tout ce nom mais
l'ordinateur tu as vu quand on a fait la
vidéo j'ai peur que sortira qu'en cette
vidéo ce qu'ont fait un petit teasing je
pense demain non parce que c'est enfin
ça ça reste dans le tempo quoi bahdja
dans l'esprit autres traîtres dans le
secours non mais parce que la partie a
été jouée il ya peu tu vois donc ça
paraît quand même logique de la mer
demain
oui après ça aura perdu un peu de son
alors attends je vais essayer d'ouvrir
lé chat
moi j'ai mis le pot coûte tamines papa
août
ouais
j'aime bien ce mot papa août j'ai
l'impression de seuil de lui dire dès
que tu peux tu essayes de te sort tout
seul
j'ai mis qu'on jouait contre les
spectateurs encore ce soir parce que ça
avait bien marché
n'être que tu veux faire des parties
contre les spectateurs comme j'avais
fait ça la semaine dernière ça peut être
sympa les mecs avaient bien aimé ok si
aulas et tout le monde était content on
vit on peut s'amuser aussi veut de moi
sol et que les iraniens sont à tanger
j'ai raté mon j'ai raté des papas août
mais ouais les mecs étaient contents et
puis finalement c'est peut-être un truc
qui est sympa pour nous aussi ça permet
un peu discuté tranquille les partis
mettent pas trop la pression nous sa
peinture à une autre espèce de genre de
séries contre contre les spectateurs et
notre foi et notre attention mais le
papa août et je vais et je vais
récupérer l'autre l'autre chat celui de
chasse comme mais du coup elle si vous
avez des idées de petits patients ont
déjà du monde mais à la fin on a fini à
beaucoup méfier des idées de deux petits
morceaux diot a qui peuvent être marrant
pendant l'estrie n'hésitez pas à nous
faire part d'après moi je peux me
débrouiller vous faire le montage des
blocs et moi je veux bien sûr sur la
zone the duchess comme j'y suis non
s'ils voulaient me défier ya pas de
soucis on peut jouer on discute juge
doit pas vous faire des flèches tout
seul on peut paraître je peux te faire
les flèches
ça y est c'est parti mais moi je fais un
bullet en fait je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais des filles qu'être gay at
elle appuyé sur jouer tu vois attends je
vais te suivre ouais bah du coup et
ouais tu fais une partie comme ça et
puis après on en sait on en sait partie
que les vieux ça parce qu'au moins on
voit ton pseudo fab libye pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le pseudo parce que bon
il y en a encore qui ne connaissent pas
malheureusement
je pense qu'il fait foncer sans faire
attention aux le cas les jeunes aiment
bien tu viendras pan destin faire une
attaque a serial bcc non plus m
j'ai pas trop le temps moi j'ai une
finale c'est mon art 505 neymar se fout
non je mange aussi ce jeu je m'en vais a
été bien suis pas mal je suis pas mal
aller ça j'ai pas lu de tarnac
je vais ramener l'autre je veux pousser
mais plus secteur normalement il devrait
voir l'arrivée d'une deuxième arrêt la
surface comme moussa arena bull est
normalement tout devrait bientôt arriver
bientôt on l'avait annoncé pour plus tôt
elle est pas encore tout au plus tôt
solution unique
exactement et
ça aurait pu arriver en avril non je ne
sais pas pourquoi ça a été un petit peu
un petit peu déplacé mais ça devrait
arriver incessamment sous peu et ça va
être sympa les arènes en bullet ça être
encore plus dingue
voilà le grand paris est bon ok il a
abandonné ses décline et j'attends les
gens ont su modifier ses très bons même
moment s'ils jouent leurs matchs ne
saurai où la gueule je vois les français
du coup défier les mac à râler je sais
pas ce que vous faites
défier le grand fabien lebedev qui part
du coup on peut dire c'est nous le cenou
fabien les visages ce qui mettra
peut-être faire une chanson legrand
saint-etienne le grand saint siège et
maillot vert
on se permet aux synthés somme il est
vert couleur représente en plus quelque
part comme tu habites à la fouillouse on
peut dire je suis stéphanois sont
habitées saint-etienne voilà voilà
c'est nous le grand synthe et 26 minutes
là je me suis assis j'ai entendu un
petit bleu allez tous des fidèles qui
leur manière et c'est parti à gerland
c'est quoi la crédence c30 et maintenant
les centres essaye de nous expliquer un
peu ce que tu fais bah je prends le
centre je défends mon pions joue le pire
qu bon et on va d'agresser fausses infos
2h 5h 4h saint cloud l'asip tous azimuts
à lise onctueux directement vers la
colonne à chaumont fab pourtant prendre
au roi quoi tu penses à laroque
maintenant il doit tuer la caisse g5 je
viens de sous je trouve la tour s'est
très bien plus à tours pour appeler
devenir en d3 un jour venir quelques pas
exactement et vous tu va peut-être
mettre ton fou angers 5 maintenant
utilisent mal à rester avec le fou
c'est l'idée et puis on verra après ce
qu'il dira il faut 2 h 4 c'est un p de
marne 2,8 soit peu de gens partent il
entend n'y a pas de problème enfin c'est
ici si tu me l'as le tsb 5 ares comprend
des mesures non je me sortir lui mais
bien 5 pourquoi pas tu vas mettre le
mouël je veux j'ai envie de faire
grimper exactement tutu lit dans mon jeu
c'est la livre ouvert mais je sais pas
en fait ce que je fais dam des deux
bombes en désossant choc point qui
paraît ce que tu penses était déjà mieux
ou pas encore en fait jean cerneaux
autant on va faire quoi tu peux jouer
enfin wells en battant sion at-on temps
quand même ton adversaire leur manière
en train de bons jeux sur un truc je
pense que ça vaut ce que j'aurais quand
même killer dedans on voit personne ou
alors des cinq donc fabre menace le pion
ses six adversaires à plusieurs options
il peut éventuellement jouer des cas
pour s'en prendre à son cavalier et donc
par extension s'en prendre aux pions le
4 mai notre femme international a agi
majine prévu sur b4 de jouer des princes
et six exactement et sans reprendre qu'à
valider cette avec une variante un petit
peu tactique
bah c'est ce qu'on va voir allez on le
bouge voilà son adversaire apprise en
solutionnant russie plus jouer cavalier
5 éventuellement comment il prend notre
femme va reprendre le cavalier sur échec
l'adversaire peut reprendre
éventuellement du cavalier en 17 c'est
ce qui fait que ça va récupérer et sur
l'adversaire va sûrement mettre la dame
en a cinq passes qui va vouloir mettre
la pression sur ce pion c3 mais il ya
quand même la torah je crois qu'il faut
pas oublier qu'ils protègent le pion
très important cette tour en a je crois
finalement pas si mal placé que ça mais
du coup on a plus joué grand atlas est
sûre nous pousse un petit spoiler a dit
qu'on va aller vers verger un pur pour
mettre le roi à l'abri reste que femme
est vraiment mieux beau tout poli ou
c'est un peu aussi peut-être faire
quelque chose avec du cavalier ces cinq
cavaliers eux six personnes retournées
c'est pas mal joué la colonne ouverte du
fait que femme n'a plus la pluie ces
deux tours sur la première rangée
il va vendre mal à colmater les consomme
bar et un pont km seront à l'abri à
faire ce qu'on pourrait appeler un roc
artificielle fab exactement bon je ne
sais pas je vais faire un coup mister
john on bouge le chou 4 le show ici sur
une bonne diagonale et puisque toujours
ni en b3 un peu que le mot clé des
histoires quoi alors tu as un pion de
plus quand même oui mais c'est pas non
plus le pion de l'année quoi papillon de
l'anem et peut-être qu'il sera décisif
on ne sait pas bonne nouvelle ce qu'on a
fait notre retard à la pendule leucate
et attaquer femme qui colle matin là
c'est bien parce que 6000 flambée 3,5
qui avaient les premiers 3 c'est un peu
idiot puisque sarr permettrait de de
dédoubler les pions et de refaire un
îlot un îlot de pions même de reprendre
de a et refaire un vrai hymne aux deux
pions mais alors est-ce qu'on bouge ce
truc on verra plus tard
on sent différent j'aurais peut-être dû
faire fois ci je n'aime pas regarder se
prendre aussi ce ne soit pas maman bon
écoute je repars nettement garage sis
juste perdu mais tant qu'on a bloqué une
part parce que son pion été attaqué à la
tour ne protégeait pas donc il y avait
une masse de fou prend ces trois femmes
qui repart et c'est vrai que ce roi noir
peut se retrouver un peu faibles femmes
cette crise nous faire ça ça va
peut-être mettre son cavalier vers f4
impossible et fat qui l'empêchent un
petit peu puisque dans les variantes
avec francis dame prend h 6/4 et les f4
à peut-être le pion g6 qui peut traîner
abandonné puisque f7 ne protégera plus
g6
donc la force et il s'est pris un fou
prise prise bombe à vous de juger les
comics trop de temps ce complot finale
comme ça pourquoi pas le simple
maintenant assez depuis la sanction de
plus après je suis pas convaincu que la
finale soit objectivement gagnante mais
fatiha 30 secondes de plus avec 1
seconde de plus à la pendule et une
position quand même avantageuses en
défendant je constate soit mieux mais
bon c'est sensiblement mieux donc quand
même mais j'ai payé jouez à ok ça va hop
on verra on va attaquer celui là
peut-être très bon et le truc c'est que
t'as pas vraiment de plan pour
progresser quoi c'est ça après ma gagner
un pion passer un échange ça permet
d'échanger ton pions doublé et la renta
deux pions passé les ramenant à les
gagnantes
oui qui leur manière de jouer plus vite
que fab killer magna qui va peut-être la
gagner
affable à qui va réussir à récupérer une
dame bien joué et fab ou une spéciale 1
c'était pas la partie du siècle
et ça a été un peu construit je sais pas
mais je crois pas être beaucoup mieux
pendant une main bon moment de la partie
c'est un pion plus mais doubler les
compensations mais ok le flou trois fois
ci ça c'est vraiment ridicule si je fais
fois justice dira que c'est parce que je
sois calme mieux à ce moment là puisque
je venais c'est prendre le cavalier
aussi allumé la structure et du coiffeur
le roi alors les mathis qui me défie à
lesparre et on part sur mathis la
british ma man 4 5 un truc on met deux
pièces au centre écossaise
bien bien vous êtes ya rien ou vidéo
très possible la femme c'est pas mal je
deteste donc qui est pas dans le coup
qu'on conseille côté noir
as tu un jeu qui a aidé b5 pas mathis
qui regardent les vidéos mathis qui
apprend way s'est passé ça fait un
moment que je dis faut pas qu'on leur
apprenne à bien jouer aux échecs qui
vont devenir que tu peux nous apprennons
mais faut qu'on commence à raconter de
la merde dans les vidéos y en a marre
quand les mecs après que débite 15 coup
de théorie matisse va devenir un grand
maître de mémoire si tu veux faire ça ok
c'est ce riche mais enfin c'est pour
pour pour former des grands maîtres de
mémoire de partout femme ça sert à rien
du stream a échoué dans sa mission
bon lorsqu'on parle c'est bon donc le
problème des normes sur la patrouille
fiction la vue là la série sur
l'écossaise mais c'est que fabien et
gagnez un pion mais quand cavaliers
arrivé en bessin que je suis revenu je
reviens la position en fait il était
obligé de défendre en bougeant droits
sur les autres coûts y avait des
problèmes faux si vous voulez aller plus
loin voir notre série sur les causses
est tout est expliqué on va pas perdre
du temps maintenant et donc femmes avec
leurs enfants dès 8 et pas forcément
très bien alors c'est vrai qu'il a un
pion plus c'est vrai que que matisse à
des pions doublet mais mes femmes et des
rockets fab animal à se développer va
peut-être se prendre un fou un f4 qui va
menacer son pion puis une idée qui peut
faire le kéké menace aussi mais avec c4
c5 qui peut arriver aussi pour pour
déloger de pions et qui viendra en d6
mais en fait je pense ceux d'autrefois
trois plaidé pendant près deux fois à
trois avec l'idée sur pions prend m et
surtout prend ces six familles arrivent
tôt pout reprend à 3
mais bon là c'est de faire du c4 c5 et
ouvrir ou rouvrir la colonne des se
débarrasser des pions doublé ce serait
logique on s'attendre à une partie de
leur manière de matisse pareil si tu
suis déjà une bonne variante théorique
on en a un petit peu parlé des afab tu
auras c'est plus facile de jouer au
hockey mais c'est pas facile on était
mieux c'est pas trop dur jo de chance
mais bon faut même je teste voir s'ils
écoutent site les vidéos donc oui il
écoute il a passé le test
alors il écoute il écoute bien sûr
qu'ils écoutent il ne fait que ça
d'ailleurs se lève ou et j'écoute les
vidéos greenstream combien as-tu à
l'école tu vas fin où j'ai eu quatre
brevets dégage ça ne m'intéresse pas moi
je suis au centre l'écossaise dame h4
beaucoup plus important
donc tu vas est ce que finalement c'est
une bonne chose tu as ses parents
peut-être regarde la vidéo jouit on peut
voir maintenant que tu as très très bien
appris les vidéos bitstream d'être
complètement inutile du coup affronter
géographie quels sont les capitales quoi
veux tu devenir comme ces deux abrutis
que tu vois sur ta vie sur les vidéos
quoi c'est un exemple à suivre
excuse moi j'ai maintenant compris que
c'était une erreur
jamais je ne deviendrai comme bord du
tout moi je me bats pour résister quand
un de plus mais mais quoi
mais toujours du contre je bien sûr pour
les blancs alors les menaces de faire
dame tranquille alliée vu quelques lois
et peut-être du calice et 5 aussi parce
que c'est si grave affaire
bahmani ce qui joue pas mal mathis tu
fais une bonne game en fait qu'ils
défendent cavaliers f5 et qui est vouée
à la fab a peut-être réussi à un petit
peu renversé la vapeur même pas dit non
je ne me suis pas pris d'attac hyper
violent qui perd vite avec des
activistes sur le roi à poil ni
répression trouve earth mais ça s'est
calmé kilic la grippe a un peu faiblard
pas très à l'aise avec les noirs comme
ici mais quasi dans ce genre de
variantes avec les burqa matra être
précis tu peux pas attaquer les yeux
fermés la partie qu'on avait montré je
pense qu'une partie de spector contrat
ce bail par abily et il avait bien
attaquer quoi bon écoute prendre un truc
[Musique]
chine avec plaisir est là le truc
d'échanger les dames le problème pour
pour mathis et que son aventin sont
contre je résidais quand même sur la
table du roi adverse et en échangeant
les dames et facilite un peu facile à la
vie de deux femmes qui maintenant à
leroy qu'il faut s'entre il va jouer du
fouet aux six tours 8
il va colmater va mettre les tours sur
la colonne ouverte
il va tout et changer la structure de
pions de matisse c'est pas beau à voir
quoi mais bon comme pas mal loti bonne
partie bahman partie surtout que mathis
est classé 1125 fab
voilà du haut de tes 2005 avons un tas
tout mémoriser qua non tu connais c'est
la théorie plus long avec mathis grands
maîtres de mémoire tu prenais c'est tout
quand même jusque là tu connais non j'ai
joué un peu au hasard
en plus j'ai joué un truc je sais
douteux pour tester
pour sortir de cette réputation qui te
colle à la peau qua non à ça j'ai pas
trop cette réputation
la bafin situe la fin je me l'octroi pas
cette future 400 grands maîtres des
changes
enfin qu'ils échangent les tours afin de
vannes passé le plus rare le pion à est
un pion passé le cavaliere a beaucoup de
mal à défendre contre un pion du bord et
donc ça très très simple à gagner pour
fab qui va échanger qui va probablement
faire un petit coup de bessengue pour
éviter les c4 et poussé trois cas c'est
ce qu'on imagine en va-t-il de le faire
at il à voir nous contredire non il le
fait protège le pion g6 pour éviter que
mathis ne se procurent un pion passé et
le pion à fil à noter une jolie focal du
fou sur le cavalier adverse donnait
toujours contre 3,15 et maintenant
l'option à phil irrémédiablement mais
mathis corps a sorti une belle partie
notre premier match 3 aura mis en
difficulté je leur au centre mais de
l'attak on pousse on pousse hockey à
l'efa bon se bat alors seulement se bat
moi j'attends un nouveau défi donc tu as
peut-être des défis on vérifie sur ta
liste des défis quand même pas là je
n'ai pas vérifié
désolé c'est là que se situe le défi
mais je l'accepté aschbach 33 est donc
allé à tuer des 4 7 6
les petites trop beau ce qu'ils vont
faire plaisir à qui m
tu t'es mis aussi alors je suis tu me
provoque moi je te mange
si c'est pas un très bon coup parce que
tu vas pouvoir mettre le plancher ces
quatre en première et en gros pas dire
quand les blancs font sujet 5 dans la
trop pauvres ce qui très souvent ils
veulent échanger dans les six on sera le
provoquer c'est comme dans la rue sous
l'humour dont elle voulait 5 à 6 n'est
pas de raison c'est pas comme l'espagnol
et hewitt en doute pas a prédit tu
regarde mes parties et aime bien les
petits plans sur la trompe au bois c'est
tranquille ce genre truc tu es solide du
metalist pression elle dame externe chez
que je n'ai que trois quilles au 2 mai m
je sais pas pourquoi je sois passé en
phase avec le droit qui avait eu dans
l'idée que je veux garder mon fou j'ai
deux ouverts mais bon là tu peux plus
loin possible sur scipion prend le
problème c'est qu'elle est pions sont
très ouverts donc si on peut parfois
faire du cavalier d2 avec l'idée de
protéger ses cartes et faire f 4 avec
tempo et de quatre pour que je vais
jouer je pense je veux jouer kigali ce
que la main non je veux forte qui ait
des quatre peut-être monde
on va attendre je serai pas face à jeudi
a manqué les quatre si l'on sait
sûrement très bien mais déjà d'évoquer
les quatre coups d'avancé tant pis pour
ces quatre mais on a une carte des pions
en garde des pièces mais un truc c'est
que les noirs ont du mal à trouver un
bon plan t'es tu sais si c'est pas mal
vert bleu ou vert beaucoup de trucs avec
un truc ici
c'était l'idée de base et puis on va
en d4 qui est assez bien placé ses six
umeå saucisses et là le problème c'est
que si le pion reprend la structure des
noirs qui verra ce sera dès 6 7 6 9 7 et
ça va être dégueulasse car tout g7 qui
fait un peu la tête
alors ça c'est bien joué pour attirer le
fou bon je peux gagner bessette minimum
bon de te dire pourquoi pas en faute
fabien tu veux gagner 17 ans prenant
aussi c'est en prenant 17 avec le foie
sinon on peut travailler re 4 je suis
tout ouvrir essayé de faire un peu de la
tête je suis pas je suis pas sûr je
tendrais parti et j'ai trouvé que c'est
que si tu te prends des 5 tu prends un
f5 sur ouais ça prend au 4g prendre
aussi sésame h5 et c'est un peu
désagréable je sais pas trop comment ça
marche pas je suis pas disent on veut
dire les blancs n'y a pas besoin de deux
coups pieds de jeu dans le monde c'est
quand même très bien ce que ça peut
prendre b sat ou quoi oui mais là le
truc c'est que tu as de prendre f 5 et 6
reprends ta tête tu as cassé sa
structure la longue et moins d'un côté
tu gagneras pas bessette
après tu peux aussi prendre 6 points 9 5
et prendre 17 en prendre soin mais oui
c'est vrai que tu compliquer le jeu et
qu'au final c'est drôlement t'as pas
besoin
t'as pas besoin de création de prendre
s'il vous prend que venir en des cinq
passants sont calmes le c7 et qui peut
attaquera le faut avec l'autre cavaliers
bref cinq caïds et 5 ça paraît juste
gagnant pour fab
et si le four recul qui a validé 5
arrive quand même et là il ya trop de
menaces aux menaces de venir dès 7 pour
la fourchette on menace la dame en rêve
si on menace le faux f5 va tout protégé
avec les noirs puisque dame des huit qui
serait le seul pour éviter cavaliers
c'est cette rencontre cavaliers pour un
f5 et sur dame g6 fab va peut-être faire
cavalier prime 50 premiers puis
cavaliers s'essaie depuis qu'ils avaient
les prend à 8 il y aura en plus un petit
du coup je vais prendre du cavalier qui
me salir ce traitement vers en d4
probablement prendre mais fabre et fera
une découverte
après même si ennahda ne donnera plus
juste prendre un et on en a eu deux
pièces pour la tour c'est très bien mais
bien sûr si on peut gagner une dame va
pas on va pas se priver non calme en
bonbons ph barre de tâches par une autre
le programme apollo
ouais tu prends qui bat j'attends un
défi mais c'est marrant que les gens te
défie parfois je vais je croulait sous
les défis quoi qu'ils disent qu'ils font
mais peut-être parce qu'ils m'ont
rajoutant un ami sûr tu es comme suit
pas ce qu'ils foutent
est-ce que tu as beaucoup d'amis sur
facebook au lendemain journée à chaque
fois plus on est jeune on rajoute tout
le temps je t'ai tout le monde
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas où se jouent
à sa connais pas ton nombre d'animaux
non si un truc comme sur facebook où tu
peux voir rapidement un truc assez sous
call a donc quai des bulles en prennent
le centre donc les noirs je ne sais pas
trop ce que ça vaut ce qu il n'ya pas
1992 sur l'écrit duo les tontons encore
merci family pour la mastercard hier
vers le berceau de rien de rien du coup
on merci pour le pour les remerciements
à tu verses vs j'aimerais qu'on peut
dire merci de m'avoir remercier quoi je
remercie revenir massivement m haies
ladji août
mais je te contre remercie le maire du
mans tu développes tranquille ou des
vieilles parties qui avaient comme ça
des fois nous au vide schiele comme ça
c'est mon avis ce mi moyens pour les
noirs mais se mijote quoi mais j'entends
par semaine soit on va sortir un
cavalier parce que notre qualif 5 contre
angers 4 on repart m'intéresse pas à ce
que je prends ce truc tu as he likes
supprimerait simuler un objectif c'est
de jouer en du latin on ce jour se
jouera t inquiète pas toi je veux dire
aux gens ils te dirai peut-être même
plus qui ont vu la terre reste est un
peu dommage de ne pas profiter je veux
contre femme une partie plus longue pour
moi je dis ça je dis rien mais tu as
pour le public pour les mecs sont là tu
as la chance de jouer contre un grand
maître c'est intéressant de jouer à des
jeux sont un peu oui en réfutant un peu
ouais bah le truc c'est qu'en fait
malgré la vitesse si tu veux ta mémoire
de baisse pas donc c'est un truc que
j'ai remarqué aussi pour que les gens
comprennent un fait ce truc de grand
maître de mémoire c'est que je sais des
commentaires sur youtube des fouaces une
vidéo d'eux mais qu'il restait de la
théorie sur 20 à 25 ou peut être des
carlson des caruana les compagnies et tu
es un mec qui nous écrit bon bah en fait
ils connaissent tous par coeur mais très
sérieusement en fait c'est des grands
maîtres de mémoire et du coup avec
fatiha beaucoup amusé et parce
qu'évidemment ils connaissent beaucoup
de choses par coeur mais ce qu'ils sont
obligés mais même si glycerin parker
chez paccar scène sans connaître oui tu
manques au studio 70 db oui généreux
même si tu lui enlever ses ouvertures et
que lui forcé à jouer à trois au premier
coup et à 6 sur quatre mecs quand même
mais peut-être 27,50 je sais pas si
c'est avec les noirs c'est un peu raide
mais mais bon il serait quand même dans
le top 10 le top 20 mondial c'est sûr et
donc fait c'est très drôle et très très
drôle et du coup ça vient de ça et avec
tables des fois on rigole un petit peu
oui oui tu es un grand maître de mémoire
quoi les crous pas mal pourquoi parce
qu'il aura l'occasion de jouer à 5-4
moment et il aura un conflit qui sera
complètement sa faveur en plus il pourra
mettre le pion à ses six écoles
maternelles et cinq ce qui lui permettra
d' à long terme d'avoir ces menaces de
ab qui vont traîner si l'adversaire
reprend de ces bains y aura pions pas
ses protégés pour fab et si l'adversaire
reprend 2 a enfin qu'il fasse très
attention à ce que la tour de femmes ne
rentre pas sur la colonne arfi way la
stratégie commence mal pour les noirs
basculer la forte qu'à ceux des 5
il ya donc ce que don c'est donc il me
parlait le ancrer le conflit en premier
donc né changera quand on veut plus
prendre là trop c'est ça que je suis là
pour garder cette case forte sur
laquelle femme pourra mettre un cavalier
un jour il pourra faire qu'a réalisé 17
b6 des cinq étapes et sur le pion c3 je
ne sais pas bien passé par recettes et
j'imagine que tu veux faire du tour 17
autour des 8 et venir doubler sur sur a
complètement et il me chasse mais ça
tombe bien j'y venais pas mais se gagne
et nick mes adversaires se défendre très
bien toujours mais du coup est-ce qu'on
est content de ça c'est bon votre un
truc qui peut être intéressant pour les
blancs comme cet apport je suis pas sûr
a le temps de le faire mais c'est de
mettre un cavalier en c2 il nous faut
venir leurs 3 passes et 2 surtout pour
un truc c'est que cette perte des quatre
arrivées lemaître en c2 pour colmater un
des 4 à 3 tu vois je voulais jouer je
voulais faire forteresse ce que parfois
tu peux défendre des forteresses comme
ça oui la position est pas belle mais tu
défends le peuple ben ça arrive plus
souvent qu'on ne le pense
r le pouvoir faire des forteresses donc
mc du sli que non moi je dis que oui
mais d'un autre côté montre qu'ariane
faut le comprendre ça
en gros il sait que ça existe un certain
mais ce qui veut dire c'est que en fait
en pratique quand même c'est pas si
simple de défendre ce ne rien faire
c'est dur et de te faire un petit machin
à un moment mais enfin est ce que ça ne
veut pas dire que magnus se comprend
rien aux échecs et une afrique avec les
ordinateurs dont tu te rappelles tu n'as
qu'une mémoire de ce que tu as pu voir
sur des ordinateurs des gaz de ville a
une bonne mémoire et il a une belle
culture au cinéaste 28 ans revient sur
un même sujet grand maître de mémoire
sur qui a valu aux trois fabien de faire
le petit chiper pour prendre trois
lycées de échec donc fabien qu'il ya une
tranquillement et sinon tu peux avoir un
plan marans et roi de ces trois décès 3
6 6 3 des 5 3 e 4 voies la turbie forte
partout la terrisse et 2 qui avait lui
prend 1 qui arrive
bon ok bah écoutes je donne revanche
tout cas pas on va puis un invité qui va
se présenter
est-ce donc je te laisse je te laisse
appeler fab ouais mais je fais quoi je
le rajoute à la con qui va arriver
il sera avec nous faut que tu rajoutes
enlevé ta caméra du coup à l'eau
oui oui celle et philippe weber bien on
en live à être qu'ils devinent salut en
tentant pas très très bien par contre
paulo est-ce que ça va mieux là est là
c'est un petit peu mieux petit peu mieux
à temps je suis au maxi pourtant non
mais ça va ça va faut juste que tu
parles bien dans le bas de 3 2 dans la
sava là ça va c'était juste au début
c'était un peu bas mais c'est bon on
entend bien voilà ma femme je te laisse
un petit peu comme tu veux avec écolo
que moi je te laisse un peu bas écoute
paulo alors battu tout juste un peu de
te présenter une presse sont
professionnels donc je suis journaliste
sportif spécialiste du foot allemand
ancien chroniqueur sur l'after
l'émission la plus populaire du foot en
france entre 2009 et 2014
eurosport jusqu'en 2015 aujourd'hui j'ai
immigré en suisse même si j'habite
toujours saint-etienne et je suis un
grand fan des échecs depuis mon plus
jeune âge
l'art du coup des échecs allemand des
échecs français s'est un peu c'est un
petit peu compliqué j'ai vécu une
dizaine d'années en allemagne
donc c'est un petit peu différent j'ai
envie tu arraches ce n'est pas jouer le
lotier au niveau du jeu par exemple
c'est très différent au niveau de la
réalisation évidemment même si c'est un
cliché je préfère ali nation allemande
mais au niveau de la créativité par
exemple des joueurs français je prouve
que les français sont pas mauvais ce
niveau la foulée des allemands faut
vraiment quand je joue contre eux enfin
je sais pas ce qu'on pense pas bien où
est ce que pense moitié vide mais c'est
faux les sortir un petit peu de de leur
zone de confort dur mais ça peut
dépendre heures voilà oui faisons dans
le cliché
ouais il joue contre un allemand j'ai un
objectif gagner
j'ai une anecdote que j'avais que
j'avais raconté en 2015 lorsque j'avais
écrit cet article sur les échecs dans
slate et bien je me rappelle que là
c'était juste après la réunification
j'étais en allemagne à l'époque et en
fait je mets
mais jouer une défense française dont je
joue une première allemand de ma vie et
je joue la défense française et il avait
répondu que la défense tu arraches et il
m'avait regardé une façon un peu bestial
comme j'ai créé il y avait toujours une
petite guerre larvée entre les deux pays
vraiment je joue la spécialité quoi bon
un autre côté tu mets ton pion au 6e le
mec se dit avons un flux mec ne prend
pas n'est ce pas ce que fait-il qu'un
avion se pose une question enfin
pourquoi at on pu naître russie sfaf
bayeux fans gardent tranché quoi allez
vous êtes peut-être qu'ils te dis ah tu
fais un mix clic
est-ce que tu n'es pas assez assez assez
loin avec ta main il ne s'est pas le mec
qui ne compteront pas quoi c'est
toujours ce sur un jeu peut-être à la
technique de vlad déjà où je dois vous
féliciter pour le tournoi des candidats
la façon dont vous avez suivi ça parce
que je les fais aussi à mon niveau moi
j'ai tenu deux heures je suis crevé et
je ne sais pas qui montrent comment tu
as fait pour tenir trois semaines
en fait ce que tu saches que j'ai un
clown et un jumeau en fait donc c'est
très important
donc je les appelle aussi kevin mais en
fait c'est juste que c'est sous la
menace si tu veux c'est à dire que je
suis derrière tu vois j'ai un fusil et
le mail qui vont voir ailleurs si tu si
tu n'es plus là personne ne le
remarquera tu n'existes pas ils n'ont
pas de passeport ils n'ont rien les mecs
je leur donne des fois à bouffer tu vois
des morceaux mais mais ça marche comme
ça en fait c'est là c'est la dure
réalité de la chaîne l'istrie main mais
d'ailleurs fabre on a fait pareil un fab
ouais mais bon moi ça va j'ai qu un
clown j'ai pas de jumeaux soit en a
qu'un dingue mais mais ça va il est pas
trop les dissiper quoi foule
impressionnant quand même c'était
impressionnant tournoi des candidats un
plus surtout sur les premières rondes il
ya le rang des partis assez exceptionnel
enfin pour mon nouveau évidemment et
ouais tu vas css et s'annoncé y est une
force qui souffre vraiment très mal ex
d'accord avec ce que je peux pas
m'empêcher de la sortie pour tous les
niveaux et je le disais
je disais du coup non nouvelle femme
mariée pour moi mon seuil et après
c'était vraiment la mère ses frères
manqué de la tête
c'est horrible les mecs viennent sur la
chaîne cinq minutes s'ils se prennent
des notes des trucs que je fous là où je
suis je t'ai connu pour sa souveraineté
mais le truc de la mémoire c'est ce
qu'on disait juste avant c'était
quelqu'un qui était intervenu sur la
chaîne en commentaire dans les textes en
dessous et ikki 10 ans vaut 8 mais ils
ne sont pas si forts ils ne font que de
la mémoire et c'est pour ça que les
fonds en dix ans en seconde oui donc
continuer à penser excuse moi je suis
complètement coupée chez comme au
parcours est assez simple elle pas
d'autres helmand en fait je joue aux
échecs je suis parti en internat il y
avait un club d'échecs
c'est vraiment pour moi le jeu est
impressionnant du monde et il ya un côté
mystique derrière qui m'a jamais lâchée
par contre j'ai très peu joué en tournoi
parce que ma vie professionnelle à fait
que je suis parti lorsque j'ai été
lorsque j'étais en scolarité
évidemment avec un internat ça ne
facilite pas les tournois donc en fait
j'ai compensé en lisant beaucoup et puis
je suis devenu je suis devenu si je me
rappelle bien ou à la fin des années 90
j'avais venus de 90 sont nationales
l'époque où c'est tout on n'était pas
fille dé quoi et est ensuite bon je sais
pas si des attaques j'espère qu'en
tournoi 2003 il ya quelques années je
joue très très peu par contre j'ai plus
haut que ça me permet si tu veux d'avoir
des étés partie 180 qu'aujourd'hui on ne
traite pas au regarde pas mais pour les
amateurs
l'intéressant c'est un peu la démarche
le jeu était si vous voulez a mené sur
but aventure montrer des biens il parti
kwa pas forcément devienne partie c'est
surtout des variantes ou si tu veux
nathan parce que je regarde j'ai pris
goût à ce niveau là mais n'attend pas à
ce que je regarde les dernières
nouveautés sur la partie italienne et
tout le monde tous la même chose et
c'est là je laisse ça à fabien et à tout
le monde
moi je regarde plutôt des parties' feu
c'est un stade plein d'amateurs qui
parle aux amateurs
et puis pourquoi on joue pas ça comme ça
c'est plus intéressant c'est
relativement facile à comprendre mais je
ne serais pas ce que je serais pas un
peu un genre de faits tête tu connais
pas les joueurs du grenier le jour de
gagné est-ce que tu dois te disent ne
pas connaître
c'est un joueur du grenier c'est un mec
c'est un peu un toit sur youtube c'est
un peu que c'est un peu le patron du
game quelque part tu vois il un point au
dessus de tout et en fait il ressort des
vieux jeux de son grenier et c'est un
peu le concept quoi il sort des vieux
jeux
et il est mon vote généralement son idée
à lui s'est montré des vieux jeux très
nul et de défaut il faut pas mal mais
voient ils ont pas mal d'ailleurs il en
rajoute
mais du coup il se recentre sur le sur
le sur le sur le vintage quoi oui voilà
le vintage je préfère mes vieux bouquins
touché heureux plutôt que la dernière
version de deux chevaux d'heure frites
tout ce que tu veux ça c'est sûr et donc
il ya plein d'idées et aujourd'hui quand
je vois différents jeux y compris en
tournoi bah si tu veux je me demande a
déjà où elle à la culture riche etienne
c'est à dire des grands champions du
passé et tout ça je peux faire un
parallèle avec le tennis ou le moal par
exemple des grands champions ont ces
sports la connaissent toute l'histoire
de leur sport est souvent balle
aujourd'hui les amateurs
il oublie un petit peu ce qui se passait
tu vois avant la chute du mur par
exemple et je relisais dernièrement une
interview de banques larsen ou de
lautier et ben ça a énormément évolué en
25 ans mais je ne suis pas persuadé que
la diversité de ce jeu soit représentée
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a toutes les
armes notamment informatiques et
électroniques pour pour regarder ce qui
se passait avant et le pourquoi du
comment
voilà justement est ce que tu penses pas
que d'un côté c'est parce que les
anciennes variantes sont devenus un
petit peu obsolète avec l'apparition de
l'ordinateur et que donc il ya une
manière complètement différente
d'apprendre et finalement même si ça
nous paraît à fabien à moi aussi
d'ailleurs
ça nous paraît complètement bizarre
comme on joue les jeunes mais en réalité
c'est beaucoup plus efficace et justice
il s'encombre pas des connaissances
entre guillemets semi obsolète du passé
quoi l'histoire de l'obsolescence si tu
veux je pense que c'est très relatif
déjà parce que moi j'ai pas une mémoire
d'éléphant et donc ne rappelle pas tous
des coûts at on appris par coeur et sait
mais j'ai fait les mêmes erreurs
moi j'étais gamin quand j'étais gamin
j'ai appris par coeur des vignes de
bouquin sans comprendre ce que je jouais
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est ça un petit
peu ce qui me dérange c'est surtout moi
c'est la notion de praticabilité pour
l'amateur moi j'ai pas j'ai aucune
prétention je suis pas 400 suis pas
super maxime je suis pas les grands
champions qui joue comme ça très bien
mais moi je vais essayer de comprendre
ce que je que je fais et surtout
je n'oublie pas que les échecs c'est
aussi bien un square si aussi une art et
puis quelque part une science d'ailleurs
tous que tous n'ont pas très bien quand
on lui rappelle tout à fait qu en russie
si je veux cette tradition de la
question de la filiation et c'est vrai
je pense que c'est très intéressant tu
vois les colons droite pourquoi les
hongrois sont jamais devenu champion du
monde d'échecs et pourquoi on a des gars
comme participé à fait exceptionnel la
façon de jouer
donc c'est des choses comme ça qui me
passionne est ce que quelque part tu as
envie de pousser un coup de gueule c'est
sur internet ça fait bien est ce que tu
as envie finalement de de clasher de
clash et les échecs quelque part les
échelles way est ce que tu as envie de
se sortir un clash et toi peut-être
qu'en encore tu dis qu'il faut accélérer
le jeu et tout çà ou là là quelle
horreur il fait très très attention si
tu viens me clash et vous tu as très
très attendu tu peux y aller mais tu
alors oui mais j'ai pas envie de passer
sur un vieux con sur les échecs
elle est due à laisser sa sellerie ses
17 attend mines le clash et là tu as tes
à l'antenne tous dans le foot idiot
[ __ ] le mec est l'âge l'inquiète pas
les figer pour se connaître on a
l'habitude c'est fait c'est intéressant
de voir d'évolution des échecs je suis
persuadé par contre tu vois j'ai un jour
tu fais un débat est-ce que c'est plus
intéressant les matchs des candidats à
l'époque ou alors un tournant des
candidats je pense qu'un match et que ce
n'est pas parce que l'on veut absolument
médiatisé médiatisé médiatisé des échecs
que c'est bon pour le jeu en lui-même
puisque la qualité à mon avis fait
défaut elle et moi je suis pour l'hyper
médiatisation si tu veux parce que non
mais en fait je comprends si tu veux
parce que nous avec fab five tu me tues
mais tu es obligé de me re façon drame
étaient obligés parce que tu es un peu
tf1 monte obligé date avec mais en fait
elle a été obligée on efface joueurs on
est 2 contre arthur avoir quelque part
aussi
sinon je suis tout ça le gamin ça ne
compte pas une menace mais dans le sens
où tu vas nous comme on est
professionnel du jeu et quelque part on
envie alors fabre en jouant aussi mais
en faisant des trucs en faisant plein de
choses autour des échecs
forcément on a un peu partie prenante et
forcément pour nous cette histoire de
médiatisation
on a aussi quelque part tu en es partie
prenante je suis pas fait pour tous à
fond sur les bold économique on peut en
discuter il ya eu 4 ou 6 mais il faut
pas oublier l'histoire des échecs l'état
si les échecs se met au même niveau
qu'au tiers parce qu'on a mis un million
ou la table je suis pas persuadé que ce
soit bon pour le jeu en lui-même c'est
encore une fois c'est une science c'est
un art tu disais toi même je l'écouté
quelques fois que tu n'es tu aimes tu
n'aimais pas la compétition en elle-même
moi c'est pareil si tu veux je préfère
avoir à voir ça une partie propre et
faire match nul plutôt que d'avoir gagné
parce que mon adversaire a bien fait à
windham sa chute à cry for elle est
partie pour après tout ce qu'il fait
chaud c'est des choses comme ça et la
beauté des échecs moi je suis vraiment
resté un gamin par rapport à cette
activité
ça m'empêche pas de regarder ce qui se
passe maintenant mais ce qui m'embête un
petit peu mais je vois parfois je vous
écoute et vous dites qu'il faut faire
comme si comme ci comme ça et puis vous
rendez compte qu un très haut niveau ils
sont tous en train de jouer de la même
façon ils varient vérifie différentes
choses ça se joue à un petit couplet que
sai on dit c'est génial c'est fabuleux
quand j'entends qu'elle soit on veut
dire se dire est ce que c'est ça les
échecs au 21ème siècle
bah je comprends ce qu'il dit mind et
voit du coup les échecs rapide ça nous
permet de retrouver un peu le romantisme
des échecs quelque part aussi tu vois ah
bon je le vois pourquoi bas parce que tu
peux plus faire grand maître de mémoire
tu es obligé de jouer aux échecs à un
moment donné tu sors tu peux plus sortir
tes variant de 25 août a appris par
coeur à la maison et faire la fin au
final on sait même plus qui a joué les
parties souvent il ya plus ou alors ce
qui pose une autre question que moi ça
m'intéresse évidemment la médiatisation
des modèles et les modèles économiques
mais ce qui m'intéresse derrière ça
c'est aussi comment est-ce qu'on doit
parler dans un tournoi faire un mixte
entre les partis classiques
le rapide par exemple puis du blitz et
plus on fait un classement ont fait un
classement cumulé pour voir qui est le
champion
mais là je trouve ça intéressant sur un
match serait pour faire simple comme au
tennis au tennis et à bien des gens qui
aiment bien le tennis sur herbe à des
gens qui aiment la terre-battue tu as
des gens qui aiment le dur et puis
finalement c'est un pas très mauvais
exemple puisque justement des grands
champions que tu cites
aujourd'hui et ben service volée à
wimbledon ça n'existe plus ouais mais
parce qu'ils ont ralenti tout les toutes
les surfaces
ils ont par ailleurs été surclassés que
l'évolution et l'évolution des joueurs
de tennis fait qu'aujourd'hui des
retours à écoute bien de bord dans les
années 80 sa raquette avait pendu à 36
hockey c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
tous les joueurs sont à 30 kg donc c'est
pas compliqué
l'évolution physique des joueurs qui
fait qu'on ne peut plus jouer comme
avant
ouais mais bon tu as quand même encore
takero jamais gagné roland garros l'un
d'elles avait beau faire évoluer son jeu
sur un superbe villa jamais gagné à
wimbledon john bord n'a jamais gagné à
flushing meadow est aujourd'hui si tu
veux te retrouvera nadia ci qui daignent
à wimbledon où tu te retrouves avec un
federer parente il ya roland garros ça
fait pas normalement après après rogers
a gagné roland garros aussi parce qu'il
n'y avait pas rafa il ya différentes
différents toujours des cas particuliers
mais l'évolution l'exemple que tu prends
sous le tennis à mandarine et palm n'est
pas meilleure non mais c'est peut-être
pas meilleur mais tu vas dans l'esprit
géré par là qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'être uniformiser surtout toujours tu
vois la même surface voit dans cet
esprit là comme les grands prix tu as ta
le grand prix de monaco qui est hyper
envie oui tu peux pas faire de
dépassement ou tu vois ces tirages pita
d'aider des courses comme monza où tu te
fais plaisir dans les lignes droites
tu as tout à fait raison le problème
c'est que l'évolution des professionnels
fait que ces supposés différences sont
gommées aujourd'hui après après c'est
aussi vrai aux échecs car aux échecs en
partie rapide les mecs jouent quand même
de mieux en mieux je trouve ça il sort
quand même des grosses des grosses
parties quand ils sont rapides et les
performances se font que les parties se
ressemblent de plus en plus un oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est à dire du coup tu
vois quelque part est-ce que
involontairement mon exemple n'étaient
pas bons on fait un film on ne sait plus
non c'était quand même de la merde
bon ok ok non non mais c'est bon c'est
bon alors par axel dauchez fait en plus
embêtant j'ai un objectif aussi c'est
que je sais que fabien est un grand fan
de tennis
oui on s'est tu ne connais que le tennis
après neuf années 90 et dont je me suis
permis de lui envoyer des petites vidéos
avec des documentaires des années 70 des
années 80 les courts de tennis vois pas
comment tu vas que jarry gaulle et mais
je peux te dire que j'ai déjà vu jouer
stefan edberg en vrai non mais vraiment
mais je te par la télé vraiment faim sur
stefan edberg
oui parce qu'il avait il avait joué en
coupe davis l'équipe de france avait
joué en coupe davis
à 50 mètres de chez moi
aken à calais mais qu'on ne nous venons
avec s'est fait défoncer bon le mec elle
fait service volée tout le match enfin
et en fait qu'ils évitent moi je chambre
un peu parce qu en fait j'attends fabien
si rosberg quoi donc
et comment des racailles pp à l'époque
et tu es paiera à mais je vais aller
beaucoup plus loin pour le jour j à
femme tient ce serait pareil pour la
chaîne qu'on se baser vieille partie
célèbre lui sort du titanic du nimby du
taraf il ne connaissait personne
quand j'ai dit fab style il m'a dit mais
de qui tu parles ils ne connaissaient
pas et quand je lui ai sorti paul morphy
la page wikipédia il était sur le cul
une manif à paul maury fins je ne
connais pas je ne connais pas cette
personne légèrement
non mais par contre bon moi j'ai
toujours bien aimé l'histoire des échecs
mais ça je connais des joueurs qui s'en
fiche il veut juste parlé de coup et ils
ne savent pas qui a été champion du
monde dans l'histoire c'est bon fax
n'est pas le cas mais mais il ya
d'autres personnes riz et oui mais faire
le progrès alors j'ai eu un exemple
récemment avec un j'en ai parlé avec
très bien d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
si je me rappelle bien et en fait d'un
ancien un ancien joueur qui disait qu'il
aimait beaucoup un angel grand raid
français qui n'avaient jamais vu une
partie de newsweek par exemple
donc il n'avait jamais joué une partie
de votre vie n'est donc encore une fois
c'est une histoire de filiation et de
traditions et de 2,8 noah au tennis
paraître des grandes familles des
grandes familles au tennis dans les
années 80 lorsqu'il parlait de mcenroe
nastase et tout ça aux échecs c'est un
petit peu pareil si tu veux quand encore
des gamins se dit mais pourquoi riblier
était pas mauvais pourquoi parti j'étais
pas mauvais pourquoi telle personne
c'était clair les mais je pense que des
gamins tu leur demandes qui rit bly les
mecs
enfin le championnat de france jeunes là
tu parles de ribes il aimait qu'ils vont
me dire ça un jeu de cartes qui n'est
quand même pas la façon donc leur
rapport bah oui non mais ça je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est la problématique
c'est que la technique c'est très bien
mais l'histoire si on vient
d'artillerie c'est un mec qui devenait
plus des gros changements karlsson a une
grosse culture 6-1 par le coup carlson
est impressionnant et c'est aussi la
façon d'apprendre je pense moi je me
rappelle avoir posé une question à
maxime d'un savoir c'était lors du décès
de feu victor corps jeune et je lui ai
demandé s'il avait fait des sessions
d'entraînement sur les parties du corps
finale et andy non aujourd'hui c'est pas
comme ça on va reprendre ses idées mais
en fait on va les intégrer on va les
intégrer à d'autres d'autres d'autres
partis qui ont les mêmes thématiques et
ceci et cela et je trouvais ça un petit
mot un petit peu dommage mais on n'est
plus en plus la dissidence etc mais
c'était c'était intéressant de connaître
à bonhomme comme ça malade par exemple
il ya une culture qui est monstrueuse de
tous les anciens joueurs les anciens
champions les parties enfin l'autre jour
je me rappelle jeudi vlad
c'était quoi la partie de capablanca
quand il fait ses quatre avec les pions
pendant la 2 me répondit minutes après
ok c'était perdu stein capablanca quoi
je dis ok mais comment tu as fait pour
retrouver aussi vite mais dit ok mais
c'est facile j'en ris quand voilà partis
en une minute trente avec des
informations qui sont assez flous ok la
partie est connu mais il est pas obligée
de te répondre ça rapidement quand même
ses effets sur un savoir et c'est un
savoir pour moi à savoir à transmettre
ah non on peut pas forcer les gens à
l'évidence ce que je constate par contre
c'est pas que dans les échecs c'est que
dans tous les sports on oublie
l'histoire de ces espoirs commencent à
évoluer pour vivre l'instant présent
j'ai envie de dire facilitée par la
technique la technicité et je trouve
qu'on perd beaucoup plus haut c'est pas
faux face juste une petite
il ya des gens qui sont un peu chaud
pour te jouer fab ne peut-être que comme
convenu est là la discussion tout eu
aucun accord n'ayant cab times ajoutant
je discutais bien sûr mais vous étiez
défier moi je vais essayer de partager
l'écran pour que paulo étaient partie
parce que ça va être plus sympa pour
paulo silva étaient parties quand même
je sais pas si tu vois à l'écran
oui ok comme ça tu vois tu vas l'écran à
voir j'accepte select bat il va te faire
du bullet lui non mais ça
3 0 mais ils haïssent il a écouté mais
bourgoin joue un peu quelque chose on
dit souvent que c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup les livres et intégrer
l'histoire et voir l'évolution du jeu et
pas juste mettre les ordis les modules à
regarder comment comment on joue la
bestia j'ai vu j'ai retenu une vieille
interview de ben larsen genou en sol qui
lui apprend que la plupart
j'ai une vieille interview de bec larsen
et il ya en ce moment de faire une
critique d'un bouquin sur la bird way
est dedans il dit une critique l'auteur
nous emmène auteurs racontent n'importe
quoi en fait le quatrième coup qu'ils
étaient bien réagi ce n'était pas la
variante la plus à la mode mais ça s'est
joué systématique entre 1862 et 19 fois
les jeunes helvètes il dit ça j'étais
enfin je la connaissance qu'il avait été
juste impressionnant de la façon de
jouer de jouer cette variante s'était
appréciée et convaincant quand il faut
et ça va et justement je pense qu'il
arrête tu vois on regarde aujourd'hui
notamment pour les jeunes à mon avis
tout ce qui est informatique la vidéo et
tout ça c'est naturel pas pour ma
génération où on a une crise avec et
donc on s'est dit mais alors attendant
mon enfance je me rappelle d'avoir vu
une partie de lautier contre gourévitch
qu'est ce que tu veux et nous ça nous a
permis de re découvrir une autre façon
mais n'ont pas de porter des jugements
parce qu'il y avait un côté plus
émotionnelle l'impression que maintenant
où on te dis bah offrit de sa niche out
à l'ordinateur a dit ça donc c'est comme
ça il ya un côté moins psychologique
ouais mais c'est ça aussi qui a un peu
tué le truc c'est que avant tu avais pas
joué à camblanes m'a parlé de la
variante sur taille est flat avec le fou
ces cinq dans l'espagnol qui s'appelle
tête la vente arkhangelsk d'ailleurs
officiellement peut-être mais bon on
l'appelle urt est ce que c ur tf qui l'a
sorti et vlad me disais que ok le mec
plus personne jouer ça et tout d'un coup
le mec il trouve une variante une
nouveauté théorique c'est lent tout eu
le mec tu france henri vii le pion mais
qu'après tu peux récupérer la tour f 8
cavaliers gk têtu retape le pion f2 bon
peu importe mais en gros vous l'a dit
miser pendant vingt ans la variante est
enterré et le mec trouve un jour dans sa
chambre d'hôtel et où ils me montrent
ça je vais bosser dans les trains
factuel et il fallait le mec quand il
est entré en tournant avec ses petits
échiquier ils trouvent ça il remet une
parente à la mode alors qu'aujourd'hui
l'ordinateur il aurait trouvé ça en un
millième de seconde et la sai 20 ans tu
vas trouver ce truc là donc c'est comme
moi je suis d'accord avec toi mais par
contre ce qui me perturbe c'est de
copier ses grandes championnes
systématiquement c'est à dire que moi
j'aimais beaucoup les j'en avais discuté
avec fabien sur le cas peut-être larsen
quand tu regardes c'est parti c'est
difficile pour quelqu'un de mon niveau
c'est très difficile à comprendre les
partis belges dardenne et et en fait
quand tu fais quand tu prends sur toi le
regard des partis pendant plusieurs
jours ça c'est de comprendre et le mec
tu sais juste assez de même pas
comprendre un parc de l'ap a été
champion du monde adam fischer
évidemment tu comprends pas pourquoi il
n'est pas sur l'olympe des échecs web
longtemps c'est vrai nom mais c'était un
gros poisson larsen méfaits c'est
intéressant je fais des choses comme ça
qui m'a jamais impressionné qu'il me dit
mais il faut regarder parfois un peu
dans le rétroviseur pour voir comment ça
évolue et aujourd'hui ouais mais je veux
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on parlait des
échecs 960 vont parler toutes ces choses
là c'est parce que c'est un peu
frustrant à force c'est mais sa théorie
quant à haut niveau je pense pas que tu
peux confirmer et toi en tant que grand
maître tu es un peu obligé de la suivre
quand même n'a pas trop le choix
non mais disons mois déjà je jouais 22
plus marginale que ces six agneaux déjà
je joue pas aux 4 5 donc j'ai pas des
bas rhinoise tous les jours des
italiennes sur des cats juriste indienne
je rentre pas dans les gants bida les
catalanes etc etc
moi c est donc en fait je sais quand
même théorique mais c'est pas toi remain
stream on va dire ouais mais tu tues
ouais c'est pas mainstream slipstream
mais bon j'y pense je pense qu'à haut
niveau ils sont un peu obligé c'est
possible non mais c'est pas quand j'en
parle avec da à chaque fois j'ai dit ok
mais pourquoi vous faites toujours d4 d5
où tu as toujours des trucs avec avaya
6e 6 des 5 ou coiffés toujours 4,5 me
fait pas mal à trouver l'égalité autre
part est une mesure non mais c'est juste
plus facile en fait
jarre maxime au moins il défend ses
idées et je vous l'avais une fête tout
le temps il joue son âge d'or et il
arrive alors très très bons résultats
avec les noirs notamment plus qu'avec
les mains en ne jouant pas le 4-5 comme
tout le monde et comprennent pas
pourquoi certains joueurs comme ça c'est
sûr et donc en fait même si ta
différence entre emplois pas mais on a
discuté moi j'ai souvent joué la défense
figurines camp quand j'étais adolescent
et les jeunes adultes
je passais pas contre les domaines mais
tout ce qu'ils étaient ensemble ont
toutes été en dessous c'était très joie
c'est à dire que les gars on va
peut-être nos petits fours pas le savoir
qu'il faut donc ok donc c'est un petit
peu dommage
non mais surtout là pour les gens qui
nous écoutent
vous cherchez pas à replacer les
nouveautés vous avez vu dans les
tournois ce soit la chaîne tir aux
candidats jouer aux variantes et c'est
un peu donc le propose aussi de polo
c'est que vous pouvez jusqu'à jusqu'à un
très bon niveau en utilisant des ventes
soit méconnu fois que vous comprenez
bien et même si fritz se dit que c'est 0
30 ou quoi c'est pas grave
après pour great chouk pour maxime pour
des joueurs comme ça c'est une autre
paire de manches mais vous jouez pas
pour titre de champion du monde c'est ça
qui est important à comprendre la maison
à celui des crêtes qui joue par monsieur
changer enfin moi je voi situe près du
monde dégage avant candidats pourquoi
pas mais elle aimerait être à l'épaule
ce qu'avaient fait les mecs de se
qualifier aux quarts andy enfin non mais
tu vois je remarque pas en ma scandinave
que je joue souvent dit quand je joue
contre des mecs qui sont au dessus de 25
56 de sa passe plus
même à 2005 ça passe plus oui d'accord
belle pour bio et de la marge puisque je
vais dès 2005 en général pour la plupart
oui normes et c'est sur c'est sûr mais
gère que 2005 2006 c'est quand même une
c'est quand même une plateforme où il ya
une énorme différence de niveau entre
2004 et 2005 femme je trouve perso
ok possible mais ça dépend des états de
forme et tout mais bien sûr très son nom
mais où tu monte dans la hiérarchie plus
les points d'eau ont une différence mais
50 points elo entre 27,50 2008
c'est pas qu'on montre 25 50 et 25
essais par contre en mille deux cent
mille deux cent cinquante trois femmes
écoutent vitse pas mal et je me rends
compte que entre 23 et 24 il ya une
différence mais c'est pas monstre mais
entre 24 et 25 et entre 25 et 26 aussi
c'est énorme
ouais t'as raison plus tu montes plus
énorme femme mais chaque point prend une
autre valeur plus on monte on vivait en
fait on cherche yvin c'est justement
d'expliquer aux amateurs et encore moins
c'est le premier des amateurs c'est de
gérer nos respects aux niveaux pour
fabien déjà j'aime beaucoup et poterie
pour son niveau quand je vois je me
machine tu vois si on ecstasy
mais je n'oublie pas que lorsque mon
père devant l'ordinateur et demain et
devant ma partie d'échecs mais je suis
tout seul et je jouais contre guy même
obtenir ou quoi et je considère là je
vois qu'à une amie kim et ben je
comprends pas que chez les amateurs la
laitue ne soit pas plus jouer à wow
c'est pas idiot qu'un ouverture on a on
a beau me dire à mes regards lecavalier
plusieurs fois me regardent avant d'
avance aujourd'hui c'est ce style cela
quand on tient 14 5 heures sur la
lütschine je sais très bien que mon
adversaire il ya un moment jeu comme
l'ordinateur faire des erreurs et si
vous pointez un petit peu de tactique là
dedans et tout ça avec ballons
intéressants
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire sur le
jeu est tellement riche on ne peut pas
le réduire ou des meilleurs joueurs du
monde
non mais c'est sûr que là les kin la
leikine jusqu'à 2004 2005 c'est jouable
1 c'est sûr c'est sûr il ya des joueurs
comme ont fait leur carrière pour me
babouri qui était un bon grand maître
russe les partis vivre en irlande
bailly il a joué voilà cela pour que
j'aie de quasiment où il a été je pense
2006 en est le jouet contre contre tout
le monde est un jeu il ya joukova qu'il
a beaucoup joué ici a pas si longtemps
exactement bas même si chargé de
pastilles quoi donc morose et vite je
ressors l'a fait une partie de sa
carrière avec la avec
éclatée king tout à fait un nom au jeu
c'est parti il avait éclaté georgieff le
bulgare une phase assez impressionnante
à ce niveau là et aujourd'hui
l'ordinateur oui mais non c'est pas bon
parce que parce que parce que c'est
mieux pour les blancs par ok enfin c'est
une partie extraordinaire qu'il a joué
un jeu aussi le contre d'un bi albin et
tous les trucs c'est une phénoménale
dégage gambie je te faire à granby moi
aussi je ferai attention et mais sait
même pas si mauvaise qu'on vienne 20 je
sais c'est jouable un d'ailleurs ouais
et même le budapest enfin y'a plein de
[Musique]
jeux c'est what i ve yaakov suis pas sûr
celui quand même très très conservateur
il aime beaucoup jeu s'anime zoé mais
non mais le don bigg boss très beau
succès des bons remèdes qui l'utilisent
bon de temps en temps
après c'est le problème maintenant
justement conduite avec les ordinateurs
c'est qu'une fois qu'on le fait une fois
deux fois trois fois yvon des
adversaires le voient venir il se
prépare et ils vont rester 25 coude
vérité final voilà en fait c'est quand
on sait que dès que tu joues plus
détruite mainstream qui sont plus qui
tiennent plus à gros niveau les mecs se
prépare le jour il se prépare c'est ma
mais en gros si tu changes ton souvent
bas déjà tu peux l'éviter
et puis toute façon au niveau amateur
toutes les parties ne sont pas dans la
base donc les adversaires sont pas
forcément courant et quand bien même il
ya un petit désavantage son comprend
mieux les idées derrière et qu'on sait
où mettre ces pièces quoi faire sur
quelques ajouts et quelle finale sont
bonnes tes finale sont mauvaises
bah ça reste jouable importe ce que dit
l'ordinateur après je peux dire que j'ai
un élève qui est 21
1 30 21 40 mais que les prépas ça
commence quoi tant qu il était admis
2050 ça ça passait maintenant les mecs
commence à se préparer du coup les
petites variantes qui jouait même à son
niveau il peut plus avoir tu vois de
plus la tranquillité parce que moi avec
ma scandinave que je suis un peu dans la
merde si je retourne mais les mecs vont
se préparer tu vois alors que si les
mecs te faut discuter avec les plus durs
a refusé d'ailleurs investi avec pouvait
pas prévoir et je pourrai jouer jusqu'à
2004 un tournant sans problème mais
comme les mecs se prépare un peu le même
problème avec la les kin d'ailleurs au
final il faut avoir un peu l'effet de
surprise ce que mauro avait en fait
sortir des idées même si je vais même
ouverture il a échangé deux variantes
dedans j'avais bien aimé sa partie
contre vlad à las vegas c'est très
intéressant comme par les gagner mais là
ils avaient éliminé par rapport à la
théorie du robinet ou pour des candidats
lorsque je vois la catalane entre eux
m'hamed et caruana vous savez qui a
laissé sébastien est très intéressante
et pour un amateur qui a envie de
travailler dans son coin
je dis pas que la ligne est égale pour
les attentions mais mais c'est pas
perdant il ya des pièges partout il ya
du contre jeu typiquement font un peu
n'importe quoi je sais pas si ça veut
dire les dacquois répand vite pour un
amateur c'est vraiment une variante j'ai
envie de dire vos pass extraordinaire si
le 'guide' et cela nous faisons et massa
le temps d'une cabale je porte c'est
intéressant comme un prétendant au cica
les cas les objectifs suffixe quant à ma
terre tu à mes élèves je la recommande
souvent de faire souvent dues à la
française ou et 4,5 sur quatre est de
jouer des slaves ou denims haut sur des
cats pour avoir des positions assez
comment dire sun scène est classique et
qu'il faut connaître donc ça dépend
aussi des objectifs que tu as quand
amateurs ça dépend du niveau
d'amateurisme quotas en fait ce que tara
ma tara 14 santa amateurs à 18/100 tard
amateurs à 2004 quelque part un tu peux
très bien être amateur et à de grands
maîtres un d'ailleurs mais c'est
intéressant ce clown comme exemple mais
est-ce que tu ça c'est mon affection
instantané ce qui serait pas
intéressant chez des jeunes qui débute
justement leur faire jouer des ligues
difficile pour qu'ensuite ou des
variantes difficile pour qu'ensuite
lorsqu'ils ont un vrai bon niveau qui
les fait passer dans des bonnes
conditions q scène comme tu dis et ils
ont l'impression de se sentir beaucoup
mieux je sais pas en fait je pense que
quand même quand tu es jeune le mieux
c'est quand même de faire un 4/5 des
quatre des cinq pour bien apprendre
hockey ou des quatre cavaliers f6 et
aussi ceux des 5 mai pour rien à prendre
le contrôle du centre ouais c'est quand
même important parce que sinon les
gamins ils ont quand même tous une
tendance à vouloir jouer pour faire des
magouilles mais bon faut essayer de leur
apprendre quand même tu sais un peu à la
halle à roscoff quoi de 4,5 je crois que
c'est bien attention à garder à vie est
assez bien dans le jeu
en fait moi je les ai jamais fait donc
vous pouvez pas mal à devenir grand
maître sans le fermer mais je pense a pu
manquer un moment et que j'aurais pu
peut-être joué pendant un an ou deux
mais mme sarr en changeant ce que peut
être ce n'était pas pour moi mais ça
prend quand même pas mal de thèmes de
tension au centre de conflits
comment gérer tout ça et c'est quand
même je pense qu'un utile mais moi c'est
vraiment costaud sans bagages mais ce
genre de chaque fois plus que moi
sachez que nous a finalement monsieur
adrien qu'est ce que tu veux on s'écoute
ah oui le classicisme ou là un joueur
comme batman n'aurait jamais dû droit
doué seine qui débloque les idées
n'aurait jamais droit de jouer etc
je dis ça évidemment amicalement je fais
un gros bisou à fabien et mais c'est
fait c'est dingue quoi dire la
personnalité du gamin si le dia il a des
tendances mamediarov non mais regardez
moi médias off dans votre façon de
penser
mais le gars il passe pas en seconde
année que non mais je crois que même
quand il était jeune et chipé trois
semaines ont ils été classique aux siens
mais il a il a petit à petit délai mais
non mais toute façon moi ce que je fais
avec mes élèves si je leur impose aucune
ouverture ils font ce qu'ils veulent
parce qu'en fait j'ai pas envie de
s'embêter
mais s'il me demande mon avis je leur
dirais plutôt de 4,5 au début et petit à
petit sans dire ce qu'il aimait
si vous des nageoires qui fasse je vais
faire des dragons s'il veut faire des
pires que peu importe il verra mais
voilà qui nombreux jeux devra cela et
après avec qui veut commencer par jouer
des kalachnikovs wade qui lie petit
billy a le droit très bonne défense
bah oui mais devient un très bon livre
dessus d'ailleurs les gens qui vont se
dire ils sont très contents ce que tu
lis que d'après ce que j'ai vu qu'il ya
des promotions que sur internet on
essaye de s'en débarrasser un maximum
quoi les mecs ont vu arriver sur la
chaîne ils ont dit bon ils sont dit on
va faire des stocks
il fait de la pub pour son livre qui en
fait non tu vas fin fond les refourguer
quoi -50% d'ailleurs fait très attention
on peut le trouver à 11 euros son livre
comme un ancien moi je sais j'ai
toujours joué la drague ont accéléré
parce que j'avais découvert
je crois que c'était à l'open de paris
en 1983 donc j'avais 12 ans à l'époque
il y avait john jeune qui a fait bon
joueur mon joueur préféré adoré qui
avait patates et aldo ayoub l'ancien
champion de france avec nous fait un
sacrifice il avait sacrifié la qualité
doit quant à 12 ans des petites ut pas
encore classé il faut aussi relativiser
et comprendre comment ça se passait
avant et donc n'étaient pas classés on
n'est pas de parti et je regarde cette
partie et j'étais tellement en
admiration devant de cette partie que le
dragon accélérée est devenu ma défense
fétiche encore aujourd'hui quoi c'est un
truc c'est un coup de foudre
donc on a beau me un peu solide avoir
une étape à ceux ci attention les tons
de marron xix je veux dire les échecs
c'est aussi ce à quoi s'est départi moi
je ne sais pas comment comment fabien a
découvert la défense française où sont
les indiennes une chose comme ça mais je
pense qu'il ya aussi des vins coup de
foudre
s'ils ont des défenses et est
aujourd'hui je dirais pas ça mais j'ai
toujours un peu peur du conformisme et
du formalisme pour les diamants laissons
les vivre
ouais tu vas te restaurer ce discours-là
en russie je serais pas contre peut-être
mais le truc c'est qu'en france on les
laisse déjà trop vivre tu vois non mais
tu vois c'est
et c'est ça le truc c'est que
fondamentalement je suis pas forcément
compte mais bon en france c'est quand
même le festival des pièges d'aidé sur
préparation dans les ouvertures fin de
tout un tas de trucs que tu vois pas en
russie et finalement du bac en russie
des gamins ils ont quand même souvent
plus loin mais kevin ce que tu dis est
très intéressant mais là on part de la
culture d'un pays par rapport par
rapport à vos jeux d'échecs notre
activité d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on
voit l'arménie convoi de femmes et
anciens pays de l'est et qu'on voit par
exemple je dis ça à fabien quand j'ai
joué sur pièces - comme orbitz c'est bon
je suis très mauvais en orbite mais
j'essaie de m'y mettre pour le bled
neurones qui reste le je me rends compte
qu'en fait tu sais parfois c'est très
chronophage et puis évidemment je passe
par l'australie
et puis ensuite on arrivera aussi donc
je donne plein de points quand je suis
en australie tu vois comment ça arrive
en russie album donne-moi tes points
tient de ouais c'est ça et ensuite bon
tu alors il ya les états unis c'est
pareil je parte le tout bon en inde une
jouabilité parce qu'ils mettent des
ordinateurs parcours et le vécu revient
en russie donnée ces zones géographiques
où les échecs sont une véritable culture
à part entière corps non mais c'est
c'est sûr mais non mais en russie tu
progresses 1,58 en russie tu progresses
aux échecs c'est même pas pourquoi mais
parce que les mecs ou une grosse culture
tu vous plaindre partie intéressante ce
que les mecs et j'étais même très
étonnés et quand je suis allé en russie
quand tu contrat avec à 2003 en russie
un mec qui vient pas en europe pourquoi
tu vois qu'ils jugent comme ça
bon tournoi quand même mais le mec qu'il
va pas tu récites et de théories ou quoi
en fait les duos casse ils vont très
vite sortir de il va très bien placé ces
pièces sont très vite sortir la théorie
et ils vont être assez mauvais en
tactique généralement moi qui étais
bonne tactique m'amuser bien quoi mais
en revanche tu vas jouer une finale ou
quoi les mecs à 2003 c'est intéressant
je trouve que au niveau des libres 3
manque des explications c'est comme tout
le monde ils iront jouer aux causes et
mais en fait c'est pas ça en fonction
des pays
la typologie des personnes etc la
morphologie des personnes évacuées des
styles de jeu très différent et on
oublie ça un petit peu tu vois si les
allemands n'ont jamais battu les
italiens la dernière fois alors en 2007
ou encore sergio pena team et je dois
les italiens n'avaient jamais fait les
allemands vraiment perdez jamais ne
gagne jamais contre les camions football
et on essayait de comprendre pourquoi et
c'est pas juste onze composants par la
défense il ya des restes et passe à la
façon de jouer est très différente et
aux échecs c'est pareil des façons très
différentes de jouer entre l'état qui
tient mais les stratèges mais ceux ci
les cela il ya des ouvertures qui
s'emmenait beaucoup plus propice à
différentes à différentes sur un type de
joueur
c'est sûr il apparaît qu'en france le
truc c'est qu'il est déjà un niveau
culture tu vois on est enfin on est
tellement à des années lumières de la
rue situe à ses fins et c'est dur quoi
aux échecs ou aux échecs pas au foot
c'est la réac mais le bonhomme est ce
que tu dis est très intéressant mais
encore une fois le j'ai eu un énorme
problème dans ma vie de passionnés de
joueur d'échecs si j'ai pas pu jouer ou
très peu joué à cause de ma vie
professionnelle et tout ça j'ai passé
dix ans sans jouer je lisais tout et
quand j'étais en allemagne
tu vois ce que c'est qu'un pays déchets
même s'ils n'ont pas prochains mois tu
vois les clubs
je suis allé à trieste en italie où tu
dois les grandes les grandes sociétés
d'assurance qui prête qui prêtent les
locaux au club d'échecs chez nickel et
ratier c'est d'une beauté absolue
on n'est pas dans les mjc à la française
j'ai envie de dire c'était un peu long
le sujet d'un article de nokia nous
énerver un petit peu d'ailleurs et yoopa
après clôture ce que rapporte le jeu
d'échecs
c'est quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant jeu si tu perds mais j'ai
deux exemples bon j'ai écrit flèche
enfin l'article pour cela j'ai reçu des
sms je me suis pris des quelques
quelques remontrances en matière du
monde échiquéen on va dire ça comme ça
et par contre les français qui
découvrent l artiste et qui rompt des
images très très con sus du jeu d'échecs
ils ont adoré j'exclus léger recul et sl
est rondement c'est génial parce que si
tu voyais kokhba l'article corporatiste
à la française qui fonctionnait et puis
dernièrement images du jeu d'échecs
fabien connais très bien sa détiennent g
bénévolement donner des cours d'échecs
ont des quartiers en difficulté à
saint-etienne tu voyais les parents
savaient pas ce qu'on veut leur gamin et
tout ça et dès qu'on leur parle et du
jour du jeu d'échecs
eh ben il était tout heureux parce
qu'ils savaient qu intellectuellement ça
leur a apporté beaucoup de choses aux
gamins etc etc
donc moi ça me j'étais à bonifier leur
part bien évidemment mais c'était une
façon de comprendre ce jour quoi donc
voilà c'est des choses comme ça qui
m'intéresse moi c'est tous les gamins
c'est mais ne laissons pas vivre comme
ils ont l'envié de danser vos
communications mais mes formaté dans un
système de jules jusqu'à samedi en géant
ouais mais après après il ya gamin il ya
un mois je parle des gamins qui veulent
vraiment
qui veulent vraiment avoir un excellent
niveau et chaque voire même passer pro
un jour tu vois je parle pas de tous les
gamins là je parlais je parlais d'un
certain élitisme quand même dans dans ma
chance à fabien que ces cas bourlingué
un peu partout dans le monde mais je
pense qu'on trouve qu'on trouve pas bien
évidemment du jeu il voit des gamins de
12 ans 13 ans qui passent leur temps à
jouer aux échecs aujourd'hui mais c'est
quoi derrière aussi tard en gros c'est
dédia c'est comme en foot à ses dégâts
si c'est pas des champions déjà ils sont
plus rien donc moi je sais pas où est là
où la limite est où est la limite à ne
pas franchir à ce que tu peux faire les
deux tu peux tu peux tu peux aller à
l'école tout en apprenant des ouvertures
scène en apprenant les finales et en
apprenant à jouer
[Musique]
tu peux tu peux dire aussi un juste
milieu quoi voir ou juste milieu aussi
avoir après c'est vrai que les gamins
bon après d'un autre côté un mec j'ai
pas des mecs comme doubla n'enléve les
petits laouni al sarine
je m'inquiète pas trop non plus ils ont
déjà le niveau d'être pro à 12 ans donc
mais sont déjà 25 5 sont déjà là 25 5
ans et ça c'est un débat super
intéressant à faire tomber titre il ya
vous rendez compte que les aider il ya
encore pas trop comment 40 ans les ce
qu'on a appelé les grands champions ou
même ceux qui disputaient les matchs et
candidats où il tourne à des candidats
ils avaient leur maturité à 30 40 ans
aujourd'hui si là il met pas au tournoi
des candidats à 22 ans sait que c'est
compliqué point là c'est fini déjà
quasiment fini c'est dingue c'est une
évolution cercle moi qui adore les
anciens les anciens les anciens
champions et tout ça je me dis mais
finalement ils sont peut-être pas si
fort que ça où on veut débattre
ok il ya peut-être la massification et
du 40e mais le sait c'est intéressant
questions de grégoire dans le chat qui
demandent si tu as des enfants
c'est finalement non officieusement du
coup je ne répondrai pas faut demander
ça c'est pour le coup assez pour revenir
à ses côtés jeunes du jeu quand parents
quand je vais aux olympiades autre chose
comme ça il ya en fait je vois que c'est
que des fois des gares entre guillemets
dans les équipes moi je suis capitaine
ou enfin je suis selon dents mais déjà
je serai un des gars âgé dé si je jouais
là il ya plusieurs il ya des chartes qui
joue il y avait et encore beliatski qui
jouent pour la surveiller bon ok ça
arrive mais principalement c'est sa
petite vingtaine blessées dans beaucoup
de sports un fable que les jeunes
arrivent et on arrive de plein de
médailles d'or pas dans dans le sport
contre un peu plus de 35 ans c'est dur
toute façon mais aux échecs c'est vrai
que même ma part à bobigny coup quoi je
crois qu'ils considéraient que la mer
peut accepter tant de 40 et 45 rang
alors que si on comprend maintenant pas
plu du tout quoi
à 45 ans
en soi c'est comme crown hickman on se
dit tiens est il va prendre sa retraite
ou pas ou en anglais parce qu'ils ont
tant que c'est devenu beaucoup plus
tactique fab les échecs avant ça demande
plus de calculs qu'avant oui ça a joué
aussi le calcul c'est plus quelque chose
que tu as quand tu es jeune même toit
sam abaissé la note disait que tu
pouvais commencer avec l'âge a donné des
pièces en un coup faire ce genre de
gaffe de plus en plus en plus souvent
même quand tu étais quand m bien sûr ce
pagne meiway depuis quand la note en
je connaissais pas des lois donc du
temps belge était déjà morte avec
notamment à oui et depuis 2014 en fait
le tournoi de balle que j'avais fait est
bien le seul but est réservé aux 19 5
ans je sais plus quoi donc ils étaient
13 des trésors ben voila j'ai eu plein
de tang avec l'accélération et dépend du
temps soit à celle typiquement dedans
donc maintenant achevé de plus en plus
vers la correspondante m'intéresse de
plus en plus pour justement recherché
sur des policiers ont déjà intéressant
et puis le jeune j'ai envie de dire le
vrai j'ai à la pendule eux ont payé aiea
le coup de jets par correspondance est
très space comment on fait
je suis moyennement déçu c'est à dire
qu'évidemment l'ordinateur très
doucement et messi en fait c'est
terrible parce que mais ça j'ai envie de
dire c'est la nature humaine
cette série parce qu'en fait le joueur
par correspondance avec les ordinateurs
si tu veux ça devrait ça devrait être
une explosion en fait de nouvelles idées
on essaie de faire ceci on essaie de
faire cela tiens je vais essayer de le
métier de marin n'était pas super terry
mais que j'ai analysé vraiment à la
maison j'ai fait un gros travail dessus
et en fait à cause des gars qui publie
systématiquement les ordinateurs et
d'infos plus prendre de risques c'est
devenu tolérer un usage gardien tard
c'est pas contre et c'est maintenant
l'heure est à conseiller ses conseillers
fait mais c'est pas ça c'est qu'en fait
alors ça dépend des sites
chez les autos des six mois par exemple
quand je vais sur rieux cc on m'autorise
à avoir tous les bouquins que je veux et
on autorise en fait d'utiliser les bases
de données mais même un nul 1 à les
modules une fois qu'ils sont finis voilà
mais bon ça se voit très bien le
problème c'est que c'est très frustrant
quand tu as une nouvelle idée qu un
fabien entendez parler vous rappelez de
la dernière partie le gambit dames avec
g4 qui a eu on a ri et ben j'ai joué
cette idée il ya un peu plus d'un an et
sauf que le dire il a mieux joué couci
fans
donc c'est très frustrant parce que tu
passe des heures à essayer de cette idée
à regarder pourquoi ça marche et c'est
qu'il ya choix tu pourras la planter et
puis le diable elle te réponds très
stoïquement il trouve la meilleure
variante est tous un peu moins un peu
moins bien au bout d'un moment
donc voilà donc il faut faire avec mais
tu étais obligé d'avoir l'ordinateur
pour tes mais je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec ça moi je sais investi 10
pas trouvé c'est très tentant
non mais faut un peu les deux fins forêt
faut réfléchir tout en ayant le redis
pour t'aider quoi mes lordi c'est un peu
le bras musclés très musclé mais très
très musclé c'est un peu le commodo quoi
le mais qui hélas une morsure c'est fini
quoi monsieur bah c'est sûr que je vais
vérifier sur wikipédia
non mais ça valait vraiment comment dès
lors dit fin c'est son nom va s'arrêter
écrit c'est vérifiable
je vais je vais je vais regarder et
commenter les traces c'est très très
dangereux enfin tu vas faire des
cauchemars tu ne vas plus dormir se sont
ils déjà très grosse télé dans bah ouais
c'est ça dans propre dans ma propre
alors après il ya des chercheurs qui
dirait maintenant qu'il a du venin mais
bon nous on n'y croit pas on n'y croit
pas non mais c'est génial le dragon de
komodo pour revenir à ta question je
vais te donner un exemple tresseur
j'étais j'ai joué une gloire
dernièrement et j'étais dans une
position compliquée mon adversaire avec
des tubes d'acier tout ça et puis je me
suis dit tiens mais si je donne si je
donne une pièce finalement ils passent
pas à l'ordinateur le bois pas donc et
finalement ça fait nul parce que le
diable pour que nul tout de suite parce
que c'est donc tu vois ça faire
attention quand est-ce qu'on réfléchit
quand est ce que là mais je crois que
les meilleurs joueurs du monde d'échecs
par correspondance d'après ce que j'ai
pu lire ils font vraiment les 2 1 ils
font un peu dormi un peu de moi je crois
que c'est pire c'est que des relais des
débats
j'avais lu des articles en allemagne là
dessus comme quoi ils en ont marre ça
que des matches nuls quoi j'ai cru
comprendre ça - donc mais un lob
anne-cécile fra/n des échecs mais c'est
un c'est que c'est le jeu est
fondamentalement nul mais oui on peut
voir sa voix c'est sûr c'est sûr on
regarde et on peut le voir comme ça de
le côté scientifique mais bon il ya
beaucoup de ce superbe partie qui ont
été joués alors que l'un des deux hommes
d'affaires avaient fait une erreur et
c'est ça qui est beau et rechercher la
vérité peinture au hamas le pourquoi
j'adore les échecs et parce que ce jeu
il a compris que j'étais rien du tout il
était tellement tellement tellement
impressionnant ce jeu est vraiment g1
j'adore ça et il m'a fait comprendre que
fin jumelage était une dose d'humilité
mais terrible à aix les bains
je ne savais pas où est et pourtant j'ai
le groupe à différentes personnes on
voit là c'est faut essayer de faire
comprendre comme ça on évolue comme ça
ce coup là mais c'est un bon joueur
c'est peut-être le plus beau des clashs
royal réglages royal fortnight de tas de
nitrate angels mon bras mais un jeu
millénaire ce n'est pas pour rien oui
mon minecraft alors à skis aux échecs tu
peux construire une maison avec des
bouts de bois afin je ne sais pas au
bout d'un moment fab
enfin ça fait la question qu'on se pose
non mais c'est bien que je traversé les
siècles comme ça et qu on a encore des
trucs à découvrir si c'est beaucoup il
est temps d'arrêter justement qui a
traversé les sexes et le dernier dans
lequel tu vivras c'est grâce à ces
possibles si les dardenne utilise le jeu
a baissé de régime honni mais bon ben ça
c'était une belle aventure
maintenant ça mais bon je crois qu'on
n'est pas encore sous notre l'aube ou
quoi mais duke est ce que tu vas faire
des afters paulo après d après des
matches ça fait genre talent match car
la scène caruana monde après les parties
on veut faire un after oui pourquoi pas
mais c'est c'est
et c'est si tu veux la jeu je ne sais
pas ce que va donner cette finale de
super du monde moi je suis mais
évidemment avec les avec les matches
karpov et kasparov quoi donc pareil on
parlait de tennis valeur qu'apporte ce
soir pour simplifier ces labels macairo
on tient un joueur de fond de court
contre un joueur de séries de volée et
donc c'est un attaquant contre peut-être
le plus grand défenseur
dieu parle
sharon à 40 cents moi en tout cas
évidemment c'est logique mais moi ça
m'emballe pas plus que ça le fait que et
le fait que peut-être un quart joueurs
italiens puissent redevenir champion du
monde ça te réveilles mais bon on défend
on défend chacun son clocher tu vas
respecte d'ailleurs très marrant comment
les comment les américains ont formé en
quelques mois une superbe équipe en
allant chercher un peu
d'après tout ce qu'il y avait dans le
monde c'est très marrant ça ouais mais
bon c'est une bonne stratégie après je
crois que le qatar avait voulu le faire
au foot mais qu'ils avaient très vite
refroidie en interdisant en foot apple
doit montrer au monde il n'aurait warned
par contre mais l'on se rende ou qu'il
est venu à moi je les adore c'est à dire
que ce mec là il me fait penser à ce
parti je trouve c'est un jour universel
il peut tout faire
encore une fois je pars tout contrôler
la connaissance et du niveau 2 de fabien
quoi picchu tu vois se mettre là va
rester il restera pour moi parce que
quand je vois jouer que quand je vois
tout ça couine celle là toujours
l'impression en plus ma chère et tendre
quand elle le voit on a l'impression que
c'est que c'est d'être le poète russe
etc
il ya un coupet mais après après tu sais
ces ouvertures et toutes ces nouveautés
enfin tu sais d'où ça vient j'en parle
il n'y est pour rien comme à faire le
mec n'est qu'une marionnette situé entre
les mains de vlad si c'est quand même ça
qu'il faut s'y remettre en contexte quoi
en tout cas riche où ces peluches qui
ont tous fait le bon choix de seconde en
c'est le seul bon point qu'il a fait
dans sa fille en fait seulement toute sa
classe quoi elle fait son travail zouk
oui c'est super je m'intéresse plus que
caruana nicaragua il ya un côté conte
plutôt rice quand je regarde mes mains
ok très bien c'est l'évolution du monde
c'est ceci c'est cela mais vire
l'émotion humaine
il a un énorme respect pour caruana il
aime il aime vraiment beaucoup quoi il
en parlera et il aime vraiment beaucoup
préfèrent genre il est chaud ou à rognan
ouais je dégage des choses dans leur jeu
extraordinaire la préparation d'art
union c'est un truc comme une envie plus
quand tu vois qu'il a bossé et moi je
suis malheureux pour lui ces spectacles
sa façon de jouer
c'est à bassecourt il apporté de belles
idées parfois qui sont pas terribles
mais tu sais qu'ils sont un peu moins
bien dans les rumeurs pures mais
finalement c'est vraiment là je pense
enfin d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre
ce que j'ai discuté avec vlad caruana
c'est chirurgicale la préparation
d'amandiers pu comprendre c'est bon
après il m'a dit que le dan 17 dans la
terreur évidemment ils connaissent avant
mai mais il m'a dit sinon en gros c'est
oui mais chirurgicale de l'enceinte trop
bas et c'est ça exact ce soir c'est un
peu ça c'est non on est très bien c'est
l'évolution du sport aujourd'hui dac le
vainqueur qui est intéressant et on
oublie plan tous les sports il ya riche
en cocon jamais rien gagné ou très peu
et qui sont pourtant des génies je
m'excuse de revenir au football mais je
suis sûr que tu parles aux jeunes
mathiew de lovenox qui connaissent pas
la blague ne connaît ni les supporters
du dinamo kiev de lobanovski par exemple
c'est évident dire tu vois ça tapait pas
c'est comme le borussia monchengladbach
des années 70 ce que ça représente pour
les jours c'est des choses comme ça et
même classe n corps chaud et ces mecs là
n'ont jamais été champions du monde et
on vas et tu vois sur les réseaux
sociaux mais elle n'a pas changé les
regarde son et je regarde la façon dont
tu te donne du plaisir en jouant
non mais c'est sur un an mais ça je suis
d'accord avec toi mais bon après après
face à un mec comme carl scène tu vois
je suis presque content d'avoir caruana
parce qu'il peut y avoir match une
quinzaine c'est le génie des autres
choses mais autre chose au water que tu
vois c'est parti
encore une fois monsieur soit vous
concours regarde exceptionnel comment il
va les gagner mais tu tu rêves tu
remarques que là encore il ya un second
temps qui est sur la chaise vide stream
tu vois tu dis ça je dis rien tu as
qu'il y aurait pas finalement
tu vois une espèce dhombres qui planait
au dessus des échecs mondiaux je sais
c'est laurence et c'est laurent oui il
faut faire attention aux autres parce
qu'il ya un élément fin c'est justement
ce à quoi ce serait très dangereux
non mais l'euro l'euro l'impressionnent
tu vois moi tue c'est un gars je les lui
faut au téléphone pour parler de
cornouaille c'était assez impressionnant
de la gentillesse déjà moi je voulais
juste tirer un coup de chapeau à tous
vos consultants qui sont venus cornet
être mat et je lui en veux oublier
sylvain que je peux n'est pas peu fier
que si beaucoup tout ce qu'il fait à
côté des échecs juste comme ça comme le
scrabble si je me rappelle bien monsieur
comme ça ouais c'est impressionnant moi
j'ai envie de connaître ces mecs là tu
vois c'est je suis journaliste
c'est des mecs là j'ai envie de les
connaître c'est parce que je retourne
tous les jours quand je vais faire mes
courses tout comme ça voilà mais c'est
sûr qu'ils sont ils sont tous cool
sébastien joie sébastien joie aussi un
profil intéressant qui est passé qui est
passé deux jours pour la peine mais un
métier pas passer longtemps qui est
vraiment très très cool car si un
parcours atypique et intéressant pas bin
oui encore une fois je m'excuse si j'ai
pas citer tout le monde mais c'est c'est
impressionnant la gentillesse de ces
gars là comment et explique comment ceci
comment cela je suis pas sûr que mon
idole française alors que la même chose
non négligeable c'était le thème bel
outil sa propre génération c'est
impressionnant mais il est effarant il
s'est estompée au tournage et theo
walcott a tu fais un petit tacle quand
même quoi le petit tacle ouais mais il
n'a pas été champion d'europe et il a
été champion d'europe dans les joueurs
français la question pour le chat
c'est pas un son pas joué qu'une fois
donc c'est impressionnant et c'est
intéressant à voir ces choses là comment
ça évolue
je ne sais pas non plus encore une fois
je sais pas comment tu as fait pour
tourner les communes chez vous 2 heures
une ronde de chez tes morts donc mais
j'étais vraiment donné mon secret en
fait j'étais sérieux tout alors vas
lévesque ne me croient pas et c'est
justement ce qui fait chier les clones
si tu as une 10e et quand aussi on vient
devant l'écran et qu'on le dit tu as il
me dit ça et me dit les gens vont réagir
jérémy ne vous croiront pas ces mecs
rigolons il vous ils vous crache conçu
quoi ça c'est un truc qui est très très
bien montée paulo c'est en tout cas je
constate on regarde le chat lape ya
quelques personnes qui se souviennent de
moi au vivant voire c'est pour ça qu'il
faudrait faire un after après carlson
caruana je sais pas fin fond refait le
match sur aff
avant ça tu sais que philippe auclair
joue aux échecs aussi il connaissait
très bien le film a nous connaissez très
bien le des fat mike ce qui était pour
moi un joueur extraordinaire avec une
vie ordinaire de l'année soit 30
secondes dit qu'ils étaient assez
j'avais 80 pardon c'est des choses
voilà à quoi ça serait sympa que tous
les collèges entre guillemets un peu
connue d'un peu connu en france ou à
l'étranger viennent sur bitstream pour
essayer de discuter pourquoi ils ont
aimé le jeu des gels pourquoi te dis
pourquoi pas quoi mais c'est vrai que
j'ai fait c'est surtout qu'il ya des
gens très connus qui joue aux échecs en
france notamment je sais je vais pas
dire de nom mais je sais qu'il y en a un
ancien premier ministre qui joue aux
échecs
je sais qu'on a un mec qui aurait pu
être président notre pays qui était
énorme favori aux présidentielles qui
joue aussi aux échecs on a les gens très
connus qui joue aux échecs en france
je vois que tu veux dire mais l'institut
trop conservateur
oui non mais possible et j'apparais
qu'il ya peut-être même notre président
actuel joue aux échecs ça ça
m'étonnerait pas c'est pourquoi aussi
mais ça c'est terrible à dire de cette
façon de ne pas de ne pas en parler
d'une façon moi je suis très influencée
donc eric eu plusieurs années en
allemagne
j'étais très influencé par la culture
ashkénazes en captant c'est le jeu
d'échecs tu vois c'est un truc c'est
impressionnant la transmission la
transmission la tradition les mots qu'on
utilise
aux échecs qui viennent de la culture
ashkénaze et on n'en parle jamais mais
c'est toujours comme ça messieurs oui
non mais on t'écoute en lui le tchad et
on fait on fait feu de tout bois tu en
es on est sur tous les fronts ou de tout
bois voilà et quelques piges et ouais et
je me rappelle à l'after par exemple à
un soir on avait réussi avec
philippaerts a commencé une riche
l'arroseur à l'antenne les autres
comprenez rien davant et voilà on avait
réussi à placer sa encore et toujours
que liverpool et palerme et c'était très
sympa tu vois moi par exemple sur une
radio comme rmc sport ouais les mecs ne
parle jamais des chèques enfin je veux
dire tu pourrais avoir un mais quand on
donne et qui dit bon je sais pas si on a
des candidats aux échecs l'américain
fabiano caruana remporté de tournoi et
affrontera magnus carlsen champion du
monde en novembre
tu as ça peut quand même être dit sur un
truc comme rmc enfin je veux dire mon et
moi tu vois moi je dis que les échecs tu
vois si c'était un appartement dans le
sport ce serait les chiottes vraiment
non mais vraiment tu vas tu allais et
puis pas les chiens tout à la douche je
suis assez vraiment là la pièce décalée
où tu sais c'est ça en fait les échecs
j'ai l'impression dans le monde du sport
ces réserves n'ont pas nous ne sommes
pas un pays
malgré notre tradition échiquéenne faut
pas oublier le café de la région ce duel
avec les anglais etc
on a complètement oublié ça en france il
n'y a pas de transmission n'a pas la
transmission du savoir et moi c'est une
chose que je même si je suis un peu
vieux con par rapport à ça c'est des
fous de moi qui me m'horripile et
m'énerve très rapidement le deuxième
chose et là tu as raison mais c'est
aussi l'évolution de la formation cours
de nos publics vers la part à la
formation de plus en plus réduite on que
ça c'est lié à mon métier qui évolue
comme ça j'aime regrette aussi comme la
plupart de ces personnes que je connais
mais c'est vaut mieux parler football
l'omniprésence du football mais regarde
je te crois un exemple le bayern munich
qui n'ont pas une cellule échec le
werder de brême j'arrête là si si si et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fronce ont fait
pas ça non mais je vais te dire un truc
paulo d'ailleurs qui qui qui va qui va
étonner mais moi quand j'ai lancé la
chaîne youtube soit en français ouais
parce que bon j'avais eu des problèmes
professionnels de travail famille
j'étais tombé sur un truc
c'était très mal passé j'ai commencé ce
truc là qu'il y avait déjà commencé je
vais le faire en france et on va bien
voir ce que ça donne mais tout le monde
m'a dit t'es malade les échecs sur
youtube ça intéressera personne personne
n'a jamais regardé par en attendant joie
que j'ai des potes qui ont des chaînes
youtube on se fait des lives on se fait
des title tuesday la mare dit on et 620
vas tu vois c'est un des plus gros live
sur youtube pendant que pendant qu'on
faisait le truc tu vois par exemple
donc en fait je pense que si on commence
à parler d'échec ont montré que c'est un
sport fun
tu vas convainquons parler d'échec comme
il faut en parler comme tu fais du grand
public
tu quand tu parles du foot à la radio je
veux dire si j'imagine que quand tu as
je sais pas moi rudi garcia qui parle le
foot avec ses avec avec les adjoints à
marseille ça va être moins fun que que
l'after que l'after sur rmc on est
d'accord mais genre si tu parles de
manière fun des échecs et où c'est un
jeu qui est très marrant fait face à
adrian on est d'accord mais en plus
c'est d'autant moins je suis fâché
l'accord respecte d'autant plus qu'avec
les nouvelles technologies et l'économie
digitalisées bas les échecs sont faits
pour ça by cc ce que vlad a théorisé il
ya huit ans quand il m'a dit les échecs
c'est le sport des hipsters le
fantastique comme phrase non mais c'est
comme phrase ses doigts c'est exactement
la réponse est oui c'est la détente du
hibou là tu as peut-être te prendre pour
un f2 femmes mais oui oui non mais c'est
sûr que moi je suis étonné qu'on comme
je suis vraiment étonné qu'on n'est pas
dans les journaux dans l'équipe t'as pas
une ligne dans les radios sportif tas
par un mot d'agir faut arrêter les
échecs c'est quand même c'est quand même
pas de la merde quoi ouais mais on n'est
pas la russie on n'est pas l'ex union
soviétique on n'est pas l'arménie
je me rappelle justement dans cet
article sur slate en aime une chance me
rappelle bien j'avais j'avais appelé
jean claude moine contient que l'on la
fédération et je lui demande alors ça se
passe comment avec l'équipe de france et
trapel rappelle que l'équipe de france
avait été plusieurs fois second grand
chocolat et hindi ben écoute quand je
m'en rappelle s'il m'a dit texto jeudi
coûte 6 et l'arménie ont leur des plombs
quand il sort de l'avion de tapis rouge
si moi je ramène une breloque dans une
compétition avec mon équipe
c'est à peine s'il faut pas juger
justifie mes frais de mission quoi donc
cc c'est un peu compliqué il fallait
fois fuite c'est beau quoi elle est une
part non non c'est vrai que c'est pas
mal non mais c'est juste joué par mon
péché c'est vrai que là je ne marche pas
du tout peut-être mais ces bombes b-61
d'amd vite votre obligé de repartir dès
8 la d81 michel 500 matt tarses obligé
dhorasoo tu as peut-être dame ces trois
femmes qui n'est pas faux voire sebha
est quelqu'un qui parle de tizi j'avoue
je m'emballe aig du foot mais quand di
meco s'exprime je suis en transe ou
dhorasoo pareil avec les élections
xtream transcende l'activité ou deux
choses dhorasoo je vais faire la coupe
du monde avec lui sur un média
d'inconnus et le tu peux tu peux le dire
tu peux faire un petit coup de cuba un
telle bienvenue au contraire drogba
l'ozone ça et tu est vieux métiers mois
tout en plus il ya normalement il
devrait y avoir un ancien champion du
monde qui nous rejoint mais ce chiffre
est complétée en aiguille on sait
comment ça se passe dans cette comme ça
t'en étais fasciné ait eu à dire que
vlad ne voudrais pas venir comprend
qu'elle complète pour eric di meco que
je connais très très bien et que qu'on
avait réussi il ya deux ans pour faire
un débat avec lui et bien c'est un mec
génial j'ai mis un petit mot je dirais
pas ça pour tous les jours de football
tour atx et une houle hd non nous on
veut des blaze et moscato il écoule du
coup parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
moscato dans le chatt moi j'aime
beaucoup moscato un perso j'aime bien le
rugby et j'aime bien le moscato show
mais le
moscato sa carrière est assez
exceptionnel moi je suis passé de trois
fois avec lui dont il fait son truc j'ai
envie de bière quoi hésiter sortir des
gosses aussi soldes comme ça au feeling
est très sympa voilà et laurent baky
laurent baffie où tu connais pas parce
qu'ils passent des tapas a pu manger du
coup on demande tu verras on sort des
non pas m alors on m'a vite gens c'est
très cool mais je pense qu'il est très
très cool je pense qu'il est très sympa
non mais ça se sent ça se sent non que
laurent il est sympa baffie je veux dire
tous les grands bref on va faire une
rencontre laurent baffie laurent
frayssinet non mais c'est sûr c'est sûr
que c'est sûr que le le monde médiatique
n'est pas vraiment intéressé par les
échecs mais je pense que ça vient aussi
des échecs tu vois je pense qu'il faut
aussi se remettre en cause
tout à fait d'accord avec vous lorsque
je jouais pour le répondeur qui se ne
sait pas ou qu'elles n'avaient c'est un
battant mais c'est grave et cd mais
c'est quoi ces graves n'importe quelle
portée de biak alterneront de disséminer
ces commandes est vide
vous étiez un truc je sais pas je ne
sais pas comment ça a pu se passer je
sais quoi que nous avons assez la fille
d effacer tait c'est hayden qui qui
hélas a dit ouais mais le truc c'est
qu'à force de faire des erreurs comme ça
de les faire tout le temps de les
répéter que ce soit dans énormément de
payer tout ça c'est vrai qu'à force on
s'est mis à décourager aussi les médias
en étant complètement face
incompréhensible pour un journaliste qui
vient voir le truc dit quoi le dernier
jour c'est un dimanche
il n'ya pas d'élimination directe les
parties continuent on sait pas vraiment
qui a gagné les règles de départage sont
pas claires enfin on manque de clarté et
de lisibilité quand même oui je suis
d'accord mais je sonne n'a pas que je
vais chez des jeunes pop ya trente ans
que le monde des médias
gros problème voilà des maquis gars sur
les rachats de découpe de crèches des
choses comme ça j'ai bien relu
économique de la presse française et pas
à montrer l'exemple des musulmans ils
n'ont pas que par mes disparition dans
les journaux bien connu d'échec s'adapte
pas de monde maintenant ça va il faut
prendre 10 81 je crois qu'il n'y a plus
rien non mais j'entends que j'entends
ton argument mais il faut quand même
dire que les échecs ou un gros regain de
popularité depuis allez on va dire 5 6
ans avec l'émergence d'internet avec
l'émergence d'acteurs comme tu as comme
justement avec l'émergence de chaîne
youtube avec l'émergence la possibilité
de suivre les parties en direct ce qui
était pas possible avant donc on
pourrais tu vois quand même regagné un
peu de des nets de noblesse mais il
faudrait être aidés en plus à en parler
de la fille d'edmée la fédération
française s'est pas beaucoup mieux voir
voire même bien sûr leur au niveau des
échecs - la façon de haricots couennes
puisqu'on peut faire maintenant je suis
vieux je vois parfois des grands maîtres
qui commande
mais je me demande si tout là bas et non
mais je pareil que toi tu vois que
j'adore c'est ramon encore une fois plus
haut comme en bas âge est le même je
suis sa carrière comme tout le monde et
je peux t'assurer que ce que je vois moi
au t2
est aperçu j'estime invisible la façon
dont pourront commenter les parties
l'invicible d'émettre leurs blagues un
peu j'ai même montré saâdia qui ne
savent pas joyeux d'échec il dit mais
c'est quoi la sogepa du congrès les mecs
en plus je parle même pas des conditions
pareilles parce que parfois ils sont
dans des salles ou d'appliquer le porte
qui claque n'arrive pas avec ça saigne
ici mais moi je dis très clairement
j'adore le problème des déchets pour moi
avec une voiture j'arrive au moka et
c'est une extraordinaire d'abonnés
aujourd'hui des points voire diack aussi
qui gèle son soutien quant à nous on
n'avait rien mais on vivait sa dinde et
nous tiens on entendait parfois pas très
nettement dans notre imaginaire travail
mais là c'était assez extraordinaire tu
tu dois les mettre en direct du bois car
ce n est pas content tu voi e position
de thierry carcel voile et whitney avec
d autres ont chauffé tu vois des trucs
comme ça l'est par contre kameni comme
ça c'est compliqué et le plus échecs
n'ont pas aujourd'hui de modèle
économique
sauf senna mais ça c'est un autre c'est
un autre problème très grave parce que
ce pour avoir c'est moi j'ai un peu
bosser à la fidh et tout ça donc je
connais un petit peu et le problème de
ce truc de mécénat c'est que y'a jamais
aucune obligation de résultat est
malheureusement on vit dans un monde et
les êtres humains sont comme ça sans
obligation de résultat
on a quand même une grosse tendance à
tous faire de la merde enfin j'ai cette
impression là
mais non causés chaque homme n'a jamais
besoin de résultats y a personne qui
regarde on s'en fout le truc est mal
organisé on s'en fout il ya beaucoup de
bruit pour les joueurs comme aux
candidats les mecs peuvent pas se
concentrer ya jamais de sanctions parce
que y'a jamais quelqu'un qui tue à ce
que je veux dire mais au bout d'un
moment tu ne peux pas faire que de la
merde comme comme comme beaucoup
d'organisateurs font sans en citer aucun
et que les trucs continue et qu'il sait
faire comme si s'était rien passé c'est
pas possible non plus tu vois mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi mais
c'est un souci quoi ce sont des manques
de professionnels qui fait aussi
peut-être que c'est un marché qui n'est
pas complètement mature faut le dire
s'il faut dire ce qui est je vois moi je
j'écoute les gars parfois sur quelques
24 j'écoute les gars dame en tous cas
fait signe que fed aux états unis pour
l'asim qui fait le coeur des choses
comme ça c'est round c'est
impressionnant pour moi c'est
impressionnant après le bleu bonhomme tu
la voulais pas parce que il commença
désirent un petit peu il balancé des
histoires et ceci n'est selon moi j'aime
bien perso un chut je comprends tout ce
que fait ce que tu dis et j'adhère à 200
% après en tant que mec j'aime beaucoup
mais je suis d'accord avec ce que tu dis
à 200%
le mec il est en plus il t'amène à
savoir pour plutôt un savoir nous ont
informatisé c'est vachement intéressant
on parlait de transmission de de
transmission du savoir pour les gamins
pour les jeunes et c'est de savoir
comment ça se passait avant etc et cd
c'est un vrai bon c'est vrai c'était top
10 mondial c'était match de coviva pour
pêcher pigman je vous rappelle c'était
ce n'est pas n'importe qui et je vois
des jeunes supposés plus à la mode que
louise qui débarque que les mecs ils se
font des blagues entre eux savent à quoi
on voit mon cas on sait même pas ce qui
se passe sur l'échiquier
non c'est pas normal non non ils goûtent
à préférer notre couverture des
candidats faut que tu envoie des bisous
là c'est ça non mais c'est bon à savoir
ce que tu peux dire qu'on fait
complètement de la merde
enfin non non non non je par contre je
suis pas toujours d'accord avec eux mais
je pense que c'est générationnel
non mais mais tu sais moi aussi sur les
scream j'en rajoute un peu tu vois fin
je sais que quand tu fais cdrv laddh qui
m'a appris ça aussi vlad m'a appris
plein de trucs mais il me dit quand tu
veut intéresser les gens il faut des
avis tranchés de toute façon tu peux pas
arriver tu peux pas arriver et dire aux
mecs
d'un côté il ya ça mais d'un autre côté
tu vas bon il y en a qui le font mais ne
t'inquiète pas c'est fait quand je
demandais mon bilan de fin d'année chez
un rêve si on dit tu as quatre fois
techniquement c'est cool mais il faut
être un peu clients un effort il faut
que voilà donc c'était non mais je
comprends très bien ça mais encore une
fois c'est pour moi ce n'est pas une
activité comme les autres années d'échec
c'est un hémicycle jamais vu un truc
comme ça personne ne s'y jeunes aux
échecs
on essaie d'être le moins mauvais
possible à part vlad le meilleur des
joueurs d'échecs s'est dit car il sera
content du soleil après tout c'est
extraordinaire de voir comme ça et j'en
parlais et le toit ce qui m'énerve
encore une fois c'est l'image des échecs
c'est à dire dire bonheur est ce qu'on
voit dans la vie publique
les gens en parlent et puis parfois des
gens qui ne connaissent pas n'ont pas
joué depuis 20 ans 30 ans et qui en
tireront prennent comme ça les mecs ils
sont super positif par rapport aux
déchets ou super positive donc c'est
évident que c'est compliqué moi je vais
pas te dire que les échecs les plus est
le plus cool du monde parce que si tu
restes c'est une souffrance courant vous
avez enfin chacun à son niveau vous avez
un niveau plus fort que moi
moi j'ai aussi bossé pour y arriver gt
gt tout seul j'avais pas de croix c'est
du boulot
tassé faut aimer sa folie mais
travailler et tu vois tous les grands
champions ce qui en ce moment c'est sur
mon entraînement ce qu'ils prennent dans
la tronche
c'est assez impressionnant quand même
donc faut trouver le moyen de
l'expliquer aux gens pourquoi ça ouvre
l'esprit pourquoi c'est intéressant
pourquoi s'il faut encore jouer au café
avec son pote remplis de sang et ceci et
cela met une fois à l'histoire déjà je
je je commence à me dire non mais
t'inquiète on vieillit tous envie
surtout fab d'ailleurs je me fais blanc
qui arrive
rémo aussi n'empêche tu sais que je
pense en avoir sur les côtés tout c'est
horrible enfin attendu faire bref trois
fables esprits saks fith de qualité
paulo nous parle de sacrifice de qualité
tout à l'heure dans le dragon toi tu as
un tour près f3 qui traîne non touret
fuite
non mais paulo en gal le enfin j'avoue
un moment c'est tu vois le premier ipad
c'est qui prend trop la confiance de
buteur qui oui je parle sous le contrôle
de femmes et tout ça faut arrêter avec
ça il ya plus de contrôles il ya plus de
contrôles encore une fois tu vois j'ai
peut-être respect pour ce jeu de tous
les grands remèdes tous attachés au
respect pour eux monstrueux mais c'est
un grand maître de mémoire il a tout un
parker genre c'est que de la mémoire au
bout d'un moment c'est genre c'est très
facile il se repère et réussit ses
ventes
tu as le jour venu contre carl scène
j'ai fait une grosse bombe à le mecque
connaissait plus rien tu vas faire
légèrement
c'est de la mémoire paulo c'est que de
la mémoire le coup avec une grosse part
j'ai eu peur le juge mohamed je me suis
trompé
[Rires]
ce serait du vizir paf
j'abandonne coiffe ainsi tué au dessus
de moi mon chat qui était pensé à g4
c'est vachement intéressant ce qui se
passe aux échecs c'est ces derniers mois
avec le retour de certains partis donc
eu g4 rapidement oui on savait pas
encore une fois sous le contrôle les
chars montre que les échecs quelquefois
ça se renouvelle souvent juste comme ça
il ya quelques années on aurait rigolé
riders du vue des grands maîtres des
années 70 tenter des coups comme ça
parce que leurs adversaires plus faibles
et quand tu vois certaines parties d'un
rognant nous comptons y voit même un nom
qui ce mec qui nous parlent de nos
échecs je ne sais pas si c'est plus
progressistes des joueurs les intérêts
sont en cours non mais t'as ta pas un
truc marrant c'est vrai que le truc de
jouer g4 plus tôt mais bon truc de jouer
j'ai capitaux ça prouve aussi d'un autre
côté que l'on trouve tellement rien
nulle part qu'on est obligé de de
prendre de telles mesures pour essayer
de trouver un avantage vous mettre
l'adversaire en danger
mais bon oui c'est une épuisable quoi
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours des
nouvelles idées des trucs qu'on aurait
pensé une jamais faire et puis qui
finalement ont fait maintenant
mais bon est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à la
fin de ce puits aussi tu vas c'est une
autre question qu'on peut se poser en
très haut ils vont peut-être pour les
amateurs non je suis pas d'accord je
pense que c'est un c'est une richesse et
non pour les amateurs tata de la marque
encore c'est pour ça que dire mais tu
vas regarde l'âge et j'adore le tennis
passe aussi par des camions le tennis
pour moi il est au sport physique ce que
le déchet qui sont au plan mental ça à
ce carcan beaucoup sur toi-même avait
construit et jeux etc
et tu peux aujourd'hui de plus avec 86
est arrivé les bourrins donc avait ainsi
dû courir etc
c'était un goûter ce avant c'était très
différent aujourd'hui
tu vois si les ne sert pas de sens à
l'heure on va considérer que la crise
est faible un bail que tu es obligé
servir à 200 c'est la base
maintenant le cas maintenant ce jeu je
n'ai pas le droit
une belle idée vite j'en ai rien à faire
ça m'intéressera le suis pas des joueurs
qui me tête ou à des quizz appelait
aussi pêchu
ouais mec là ça m'intéresse c'est
parfois on each voilà un karlovic
beaucoup plus intéressant lui sert à 240
dégage la zone asie j'écris aussi alors
tu peux faire et où peut-être des cours
pouvoir mais si on part d'un âge d'or à
telle période de telles activités et ses
terrasses et aussi parce que la
morphologie du joueur
la morphologie du champion est
exactement pas exactement avec le
aujourd'hui situé son trop fort donc le
terrain devrait agrandi et ses frères
marx à faire évoluer les règles c'est
catastrophique
ice et la qatar est alors que je suis
pour la vidéo mais c'est la cata y sont
au rugby ça marche bien mais a au
football ça marche pas du tout et les
gérer c'est parce que les gens qui
prennent ce genre de décisions ne
connaissent pas le l'essence même de ce
froid j'ai remarqué c'est bizarre j'ai
souvent les gens qui prennent des
décisions laisse paris ils sont pas
joueur quasiment pas joué ce jeu un peu
plus loin d'avoir ce qu'ils ont fait
dans leur carrière entre le sport au
niveau en fait rappelle aussi le
développement du corps et ceci cela donc
certaines de nos vies et celles qui
retrouve beaucoup de mecs backing une
eau à dire juste après seconde guerre
mondiale
suivront deux fois qu'elle se recadre et
se font payer l'impôt parcourront les
recoupant par exemple de regarder ça je
connais pas de temps pour que je fais
dans les années 90 sous marin au sénat
mais voilà mais avant je faisais tout ça
ça te dit fan je connais de nom même
auquel je connais pas bien je n'ai pas
mcenroe disons j'avais jamais vu de
match mais j'ai vu le reportage
j'ai regardé j'ai reçues sur barbosa
dans les magasins c'est impressionnant
parce qu'il avait gagné une série de
matchs hallucinante à l'époque tu jouer
tout le temps les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux
ouais tu entends chesnais séquences
s'enchaînent aujourd'hui le top 10
mondial et puis tu gagnes et 40 matchs
d'affilée et c'est pas c'est papa le
fait que m c'est comment ils jouaient ce
zèle dont cinq aux milanais sarah caire
c'est un mec c'est le dernier grand
champion c'est qu'ils jouent à la main
après une évolution de l'évolution
technique des raquettes fait qu'on fait
la raquette et compteront bras oui grec
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui du moins
pas comme si le père et c'est un mec
comme agassi avait très bien compris ce
que le marketing des marques demain le
marketing et koussa et donc c'est
c'était l'idée que ce mec-là détruit
détruits après je vais y jouer très bien
après agassi il y avait 100 prince si
c'était sympa quand même cette époque là
ça ne soit pas c'est bon c'est comme ça
c'est l'évolution et vous savez c'est
pas compliqué d'espoir en 87 et une fine
fleur rugby a disparu
mon calepin j'espère que vous l'avez vu
lui en tout cas beaucoup de boîtes
vendues pour la superbe documentaire sur
le match wendel lendl mcenroe de 1988 ou
en fait on voit comment le monde anglo
saxon absorbe roland garros et que le
modèle français en fait est complètement
guérie mais en tout cas on nous devons
comme complètement périmé alors qu'il
était très émotionnel c'est pas illicite
est le directeur technique du sida qui
est jouée à maintenant c'est fini
disons par les enfants et les plus tard
1989 évidemment au bilan et à centrer
tous les mecs qui aiment le vélo
ils vont te dire que celui qui a la
classe n'est pas fini c'est pas les
modes fini en très fines on aime ça
c'est sûr
caro et c'est ça le sport c'est pas
c'est pas que palmarès et votre choix
j'ai fini ma minute jeu qu'on nomme
cette ascension intéressant moi j'aime
bien les histoires de sports extra donc
je dois être intéressés donc bah c'est
intéressant
à l'entendre parler quelqu'un qui a un
succès beaucoup mieux vous puisque moi
on apprend plein de choses
après trente ans que ce fan deux irait
fab non jeu d'éden hazard grave quand il
voit dominique team contredirait fier
layouni manqué neuf il ya un grand match
de tennis par exemple le voyage que je
te renvoie une cloche je tape carafon de
touba bon c'est s'aider beau match aller
s'est livrée après s'accapare federer je
supporte personal est ok mais par
exemple
rapaille là un beau jeu aussi voulait
pas dire le contraire raphaël est sympa
quand même
non mais j'aimerais ça avoir joué
as impressionnant mais si je mange ouais
non mais je n'ai jamais baissé ouais
mais c'est une autre beauté gère faut
aussi reconnaître que c'est beau le mec
tu vois qu'il est dans le dépassement de
soi quand même sens a rien avec sa wii
est beau quand même fait tellement
d'efforts il se bat afin oui il renonce
jamais ça c'est sa cinquième quelque
chose et vous aussi qu'on a deux rouges
des plus grands champions de tennis dont
des styles opposés pour toucher une
opposition de style d'un rapport
quelquefois ces métiers général ça c'est
génial je reviens sur l'allemagne france
à la main capable de sinistre mémoire où
beaucoup de personnes dans le jeu au
choix en voyant des français contre un
jeu complètement perdu et un peu under
des allemands c'est ça qui plaît aussi
bah oui ça qu'est bon je vois tout de
suite il est gentil tu vois c'est le
méchant a laissé à ses passes et que ces
choses là le problème c'est quand tu as
deux joueurs qui font service volée ça
n'a même pas forcément les plus beaux
matches où tu vois je vais me débattre
makoun dans les années 70 quand tu vois
d'hier mobile a trop de mbour c'est pour
apprendre aux cafards 16 d'un jeu pour
4,7 ouais non mais c'est sur un coup
franc de cohade ben c'est comme les
costa corps et déjà les machins je me
rappelle
ouais ouais non mais c'est sur mais bon
on s'y met alors alors que quand tu
avais même quand je l'appelle j'étais
gamin des matchs et tim henman sais pas
si tu te rappelles
c'était très sympa tu le voyais bon ils
y perdaient parce que les mecs étaient
fond de court mais tu voyez c'est vrai
cette opposition de styles avec le mec
est très très terre battue derrière qui
défend et tout et puis l'anglais là qui
venait à la volée et tout le temps bon
il se faisait passer mais il était
heureux quoi toi qui avaient fait une
demi finale de roland garros d'ailleurs
avec son style même incroyable
fantastique intéressante et tianma c'est
le mec qui est servi de volée mais les
dans l'école de stéphane bérard c'est
beau ouais ben j'aime beaucoup boris
becker malgré ce qu'on a dit sur lui a
dit m il a en fait une gbagbo grandes
que celles qu'on a le fameux
boubekeur a passé son temps à nous
rappelle pourquoi son style de jeu il
est extraordinaire mais une trêve en
puissance une annonce d'annoncé
d'ailleurs partenaires et des mecs comme
stefan edberg et qui n'émane son
d'eyliac aurait très bien pu jouer au
tennis dans les années 20 aux années 30
un siècle style de jeu comme ça qu'ils
étaient très différents comme tableau
cette femme une mère son beau joueur de
tennis qui peut exister indépendamment
son palmarès à ses parts à la caisse
concédé jusque là parce qu'on passe les
gans aller beau nom mais je suis
d'accord avec toi dans le sens où le
palmarès on s'en fout à la limite
parfois aussi contre on se rappelle des
champions faut aussi voir le jeu hein
l'émotion qu'ils ont procuré à l émotion
et le bonheur parce que le sport s'est
aussi procuré du plaisir aux gens ça ça
faut jamais l'oublier que des dijonnais
juste parce qu'ils jouaient des choses
qu'on ne dit plus maintenant donc c'est
alors après c'est vous le regardez on me
dit c'est bon c'est pas bon la coureuse
courges ouais mais je trouve que richard
rapport il n'est pas assez fort tu vois
je préfère un morose et beach ce que
moraux des vitres tatata le côté un peu
fou fou avec la précision quand même tu
prends ce que je veux dire par rapport
c'est pas mal ça faciliterait bon oui
mais bon tu amoureuse évite le mec
aurait menacé d'être peut-être pas
champions du monde mais il est arrivé
jusqu'à numéro 3 ou deux noms un choix
qu'il a dépassé les 2800 aux toscans
naïve je pense qu'il a fait numéro deux
mondial tu vas faire le mec avec un
style de brute épaisse
il fait 2e mondial c'est quand même
hallucinant mais je voulais dire le
livre qui est sorti de kouzminki perdre
aux entraînements et cuit alors cuisine
ouais je sais et c'est que je connais
bien en plus six mais mon copain de vlad
alors faut le dire même si c'est
pourquoi comme ça vraiment non pas pour
m'amuser j'ai eu des problèmes de santé
assez embêtant et
il se trouve que j'ai une opportunité de
partir en russie l'un et l'autre ont un
rapport mais bon comme j'ai pas envie de
parler de de ma santé de ces trucs là
j'ai bossé à moscou tout d'abord parce
que j'ai des jeunes gaulle
c'est fantastique kabila ouais je lance
donc pas violent par la panne
biogénétique ouais mais ça c'était la
mauvaise période mais moi j'étais là
s'est passé durant quoi moi j'avais un
point bien je commence maintenant
mais dès la fin du contrôle et à la
carte d'identité 3 x 3 dans la journée
cette alliance est l'hôte du kgb à
recycler retrouvé portait à l'hôtel
parce que celle de fermer ce faire non
mais ça m'a quand je suis allé ça ça
existait plus déjà c'est déjà ça
ressemble beaucoup à une ville
européenne maintenant moscou ouais c'est
non mais bon heureusement parce que vu
que j'ai vu que j'ai pas mal de faim
mais ma belle famille comme ma femme et
russes ils ont vécu toute cette époque
là il paraît que c'était terrible à
vivre mais maintenant maintenant non
maintenant ça c'est très européaniser
malgré ce qu'on peut penser si tu suis
les trucs de politique internationale ou
quoi mais en fait quand tu es la barre
j'aime beaucoup je gueule souvent jaloux
de son succès d'une histoire se on a
besoin de vous regarder du livre la peur
mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu triste
mais bon c'est un joli match fab les
faits et aurait lui demandé et
intervenir sur le chat les les anihiler
22 22 heures oui enfin on a on a débordé
je suis débordée non non non mais c'est
c'est les clones selecon qui sont ils
sont là ils ne lâchent pas l'antenne
après une fois qu'ils sont dès qu'ils
sont arrivés ils la gardent quoi c ils
te poussent kouame donc il est temps de
il est temps de se quitter paulo c'est
un échange très intéressant ta compagnie
on a vu pas mal échangé voir une autre
enfin une autre vision finalement pas si
différente de la nôtre
je dirais finalement est beaucoup plus
de convergence de points de vue que l'
inverse
en tout cas j'ai cette impression fabien
bas comme dab a été royal tu as été
fantastique tata battu au monde
ça fait plaisir ce que sur les mecs
s'abonnent à la chaîne youtube qui font
des dons sur tipi à fond et tout ça et
fab il a un objectif c'est [ __ ] et
tout le monde aussi vous nous a fait
plaisir malgré tout est quand même là
pour pour les faire chier quoi enfin
c'est ça qui est génial je pense qu'ils
ont le syndrome de stockholm et tous nos
tout notre normal de jouer pour essayer
de pas juste c'est gagner les joueurs
non pas toi c'est pas juste ne pas
laisser juste d'un égaliseur cgc les
humilier les défoncer le magot gios et
je me dis rien je fais de mon mieux
c'est déjà pas si simple aller à vau
l'eau
merci beaucoup de passer et la ville de
douala plaisir pour des petites
discussions de variantes donc à bientôt
à bientôt et puis bah ciao ciao ciao
tout le monde pense être un match fade
mais en même temps je t'aimais la caméra
pour dire ciao tu pars tu parles
adhérents est-ce qu'on va l'avoir
attachée avec le partage d'écran est ce
que je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse te
remettre la caméra du coup à paulo paulo
paulo qui a fait plaisir un polo km la
com mais moi je l'aimé moi aussi je la
vois mais du coup tout le truc et des
cadres est atteint et
et du coup à voilà ça a été le cas quand
même que les gens tous voilà calmes
parce qu'à vous après est ce que c'était
vraiment toi est ce que tu vois locaux
non le seul maintenant tu as des états
dévoilé la nympho ce que tu as l'air de
jeu quand même assez bien si tu veux ce
soir trop bien pour moi voilà c'est ça
tu as le casque sur les oreilles
pourquoi girafe tony bouton du monde
paraissait très élevé allez les mecs sur
ce passé une bonne soirée
amusé les bas à bientôt sur la chaîne ou
ici en soit j'aime du cul précis pour
pour de nouveaux stream mercredi au
travail mercredi la reina sur miss
stream jeudi les screen du jeudi est
bientôt là rhénan bullet qui devrait
arriver
ciao sort